TO CONVENE THE ASSEMBLY-
COMMITTEE ON COMMUNICATIONS AND
CONVEYANCE- THE SERGEANTS
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
BUT BEFORE WE MOVED TO THE
AGENDA OF A HOUSE A COUPLE
HOUSEKEEPING ANNOUNCEMENTS TO
MAKE FIRST ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MISTER BENNETT WILL BE STOPPING
IN FOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CERVANTES TODAY. THANK YOU AND
WELCOME- N. AS USUAL WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY AND ANY
INDIVIDUAL. WHO IS DISRUPTED
MAYBE REMOVE THE CHAMBER OR THE
REMOTE BEING SERVICE OR HAVE
THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED.
FINALLY WILL BE PRACTICING
SOCIAL DISTANCING WEAR A MASK
ALL TIMES HERE IN THE CHAMBER
AND THROUGHOUT THE CAPITOL
BUILDING. SO WILL ONLY BE ABLE
TO HAVE A LIMITED NUMBER OF
PEOPLE- HERE IN PERSON AND THEY
WILL HAVE A FEW OPTIONS FOR
WITNESS TESTIMONY TODAY. AND
MEMBERS AS YOU'RE USED TO BEAR
THROUGH THE- THE- COMMENTS
AFTER MAKE. FOR THE PUBLIC IN
THE ROOM. THAT IS THOSE FOLKS
IN THE CHAMBER TODAY IF ANY
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC IN THE
ROOM. WOULD LIKE TO TEST THE
FINAL BILL PLEASE RAISE YOUR
HAND- AND I WILL. AND I WILL
ASK YOU TO APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE AT THE PROPER TIME I
ASK THAT THE PUBLIC NOT TOUCH
THE MICROPHONE. IN ADDITION TO
BEING ABLE TO TESTIFY FROM
INSIDE THE CHAMBER. WITNESSES
MAY MAKE USE OF OUR REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION LOCATED NORTH
SIDE. OF THE CAPITOL. FOR
CALLING WITNESSES WILL ALSO BE
USING A MODERATE TELEPHONE
SERVICE. THROUGH WHICH ANY WIN
THIS CONTEST THE FINAL BILL.
THE CALL IN NUMBER NOT REPEAT
TWO TIMES A FOR THIS HEARING IS
877-692-8957. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN
SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN THE ACCESS CODE IS. TWO
FOUR TWO SIX TWO THREE SEVEN I
REPEAT OVER TIME TWO FOUR TWO
SIX. TWO THREE SEVEN YOU CAN
ALSO FIND THIS NUMBER ON THE
ASSEMBLY COMMUNICATIONS AND
CONVEYANCE COMMITTEE WEBSITE AS
WELL AS A TV SCREEN. IF YOU'RE
CALLING IN POLICE PLAN TO DO SO
AS THE AUTHOR THE BILL YOU'RE
TESTIFYING AND IS BEGINNING
THEIR BILL PRESENTATION. YOU'LL
ALSO BE ADVISE IF YOU'RE THE
MAIN WITNESS PROVIDING
TESTIMONY FOR OR AGAINST THE
BILL YOU'LL REMAIN ON THE LIVE
LINE AND WILL NEED TO MUTE
YOURSELF UNTIL YOU'RE CALLED. I
WOULD ALSO RECOMMEND THAT YOU
TO HER THAT YOU TURN DOWN THE
NOISE ON YOUR SIDE BECAUSE THE
DELAY- THE DELAY WILL WILL MAKE
IT MORE DIFFICULT FOR YOU TO.
MAKE THAT PRESENTATION AS WE
HAVE LEARNED. IF YOU'RE HAVING
ANY PROBLEMS WITH THE MODERATE
SERVICE YOU CAN CALL THE
COMMITTEE AT NINE ONE SIX.
THREE ONE NINE TWO SIX THREE
SEVEN THAT NUMBER AGAIN IS NINE
ONE SIX. THREE ONE NINE TWO SIX
THREE SEVEN. IN OUR TEAM THERE
WILL HELP YOU. WE'RE ALSO
ACCEPTED WRITTEN TESTIMONY TO
THE OPPOSITION. LETTER PORTAL
ON THE COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. WE
HAVE SIX MEASURES ON THE AGENDA
OF THE FIRST ONE IN ON THE- I
IS THE CONSENT ITEMS. I'M TO
HAVE A CORNER. OKAY ATTY
CONSENT ITEM IS NUMBER FIVE SB
THREE NINETY FOUR WESSEL AS WE
PROCEED WITH THE WITNESSES IN
PUBLIC I WANT TO MAKE SURE THEY
HAVE BEEN OR STANDS ASSEMBLY
HAS RULES TO ENSURE THAT WE
HAVE MAINTENANCE- THAT WE
MAINTAIN ORDER AND RUN AN
EFFICIENT AND FAIR HEARING.
TESTIMONY IS LIMITED TO FOUR
MINUTES FOR EACH SIDE ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES ON THE
MEASURE PLEASE BRIEFLY STATE
YOUR NAME POSITION AND
AFFILIATION IF ANY ONLY AND I
WILL ASK THAT FOR EVERYONE
WANTS TRADITIONAL WITNESS- I
ALSO ASK THE MEMBER SPEAK
DIRECTLY INTO THE MICROPHONE SO
THE PUBLIC CAN HEAR YOU- AND I
MIGHT MENTION WHEN YOU FIRST
AND SECOND. SIMPLY FOR NOTE
TAKING AND THE PUBLIC'S. AT A
PUBLIC BENEFIT. I AM KEVIN
LEANING THE ASSEMBLY COMEDIA
COMMUNICATIONS IN COMPLAINTS AS
A SUB COMMITTEE UNTIL WE
ESTABLISH A QUORUM- N. N. AND
I'D ASK MISTER MISS GONZALEZ
WHO IS PRESENTING THREE BILLS-
THAT YOU MAY PROCEED. AS A SUB
COMMITTEE WILL TAKE THE VOTES
AFTERWARDS. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS I'M HERE
TODAY FIRST TO PRESENT SB FIVE
FIVE SIX ON BEHALF OF SENATOR
DODD. SB FIVE FIVE SIX WOULD
BRING CALIFORNIA INTO
CONFORMANCE WITH EXISTING
FEDERAL AND STATE LAW SEEKING
TO ACCELERATE THE DEPLOYMENT OF
WIRELESS BROADBAND NETWORK
INFRASTRUCTURE. THE COVERT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC THAT'S
CLEARLY ELEVATED OUR
UNDERSTANDING THAT BROADBAND
ACCESS IS ESSENTIAL FOR
PARTICIPATING IN EVERY ASPECT
OF MODERN SOCIETY. SB FIVE FIVE
SIX WILL ADDRESS THIS PROBLEM
BUT CONFORMING CALIFORNIA LAW
WITH THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN FCC
FEDERAL REGULATION IN ORDER TO
EXPAND FIVE G. DEVELOP
DEPLOYMENT. AND CONTRIBUTE TO
COME CLOSING THE DIGITAL
DIVIDE. THE BILL REQUIRES
LOCALITIES TO PROVIDE ACCESS TO
THEIR STREET LIGHT AND TRAFFIC
SIGNAL POLES IN ORDER TO
PURTELL COMMUNICATION COMPANIES
TO ATTACH THEIR WIRELESS
FACILITIES. THE BILL ALSO
FOCUSES ON ENSURING THAT ACCESS
TO THOSE POLLS ARE PROVIDED A
NON DISCRIMINATORY
DISCRIMINATORY COST BASE RATE
SENATOR DODD HAS ADDED AUTHORED
AMENDMENTS TO PRESERVE.
EXISTING AGREEMENTS AND PROVIDE
FLEXIBILITY FOR WIRELESS
SERVICE PROVIDERS AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO ENTER INTO
AGREEMENTS SPECIFIC TO LOCAL
COMMUNITY NEEDS. SENATOR DODD
HAS ALSO ADDED LANGUAGE TO
ENSURE EQUITABLE ACCESS
REQUIRING SERVICE PROVIDERS TO
MONITOR THEIR PROGRESS TOWARD
REACHING CALIFORNIA'S UNIVERSAL
BROADBAND GOALS. BY REPORTING
WIRELESS BROADBAND COVERAGE BY
CENSUS TRACT ANNUALLY TO THE
LEGISLATURE. GOOD FAITH
NEGOTIATIONS CONTINUE BETWEEN
STAKEHOLDERS SENATOR DODD AND
HIS TEAM THEY ARE COMMITTED TO
WORKING WITH THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES AS THE BILL MOVES
FORWARD. CALLING IN SUPPORT IS
SERRA BASHES FROM CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL BUSINESS
OFFICIALS AND IN THE HEARING
ROOM WE HAVE RUDY REYES FROM
VERIZON TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. I THINK YOU WILL
BEGIN JUST REMINDED THERE ARE
FOUR MINUTES FOR EACH SIDE I
WOULD RECOMMEND TWO MINUTES ON
EACH SIDE TWO MINUTES FREE TO
MAIN WITNESSES. AND I WILL- TRY
TO FORCE THAT IS AS FAIRLY AS
POSSIBLE. I CEREBRA BLOCK IF
YOU WOULD PROCEED FOLLOWED BY
OUR RUDY REYES. GOOD AFTERNOON.
GOOD AFTERNOON KEREN MEMBERS
THERE ABOUT JUST THE HOUSE BILL.
I HOPE YOU CAN HEAR ME. LAST
MARCH SCHOOLS PIVOTED TO
DISTANCE LEARNING IN RESPONSE
TO THE COVER NINETEEN PANDEMIC
WHICH REVEALED THE CRITICAL
IMPORTANCE OF ONCE AND FOR ALL
CLOSING THE DIGITAL DIVIDE IN
MAKING RELIABLE INTERNET ACCESS
A REALITY FOR ALL OUR STUDENTS
AND FAMILIES. I FEES BECAME
PARTNERS WITH SCHOOLS AND
PROVIDING DISCOUNTED RATES TO
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF HOMES
WITH ACCESS TO THE INTERNET
WHILE THESE EFFORTS HELP
THEY'RE NOT A LONG TERM
SOLUTION IN MANY CASES SCHOOL
DISTRICTS WERE UNABLE TO
PROVIDE CONNECTIVITY SIMPLY
BECAUSE WIRED AND WIRELESS
PROVIDERS DO NOT OFFER SERVICES
IN SPECIFIED REGIONS. TODAY
APPROXIMATELY ONE IN FIVE
CALIFORNIA HOUSEHOLDS WITH
CHILDREN CONTINUE TO LACKS
ADEQUATE AND RELIABLE BROADBAND
ACCESS WE BELIEVE THAT THE COST
OF BUILDING INFRASTRUCTURE IN
AREAS WITH NO BROADBAND ACCESS
IS CRITICAL AND THIS PROPOSAL
REMOVES THAT BARRIER FOR BOTH
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE INTERNET
SERVICE STRIX BAND THE REACH.
SB FIVE FIVE SIX WILL ADDRESS
THOSE NEEDS BAKER BY CONFORMING
CALIFORNIA LAW WITH THE TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN FEP FEDERAL
REGULATION IN ORDER TO EXPAND
FIVE G. DEPLOYMENT AND
CONTRIBUTE TO CLOSING THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE ENSURING THEIR
FAMILIES HAVE OPTION IN
AFFORDABILITY AND SERVICE
ESPECIALLY AS OUR STATE
CONTINUES TO DEAL WITH YEAR
ROUND NATURAL DISASTERS.
IMPACTING THE ACCESS TO
EDUCATION HEALTH AND SOCIAL
SERVICES AND WE'RE PARTICULARLY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE EDUCATION
EQUITY CHALLENGES POSED BY
UNEVEN ACCESS TO BROADBAND
INTERSTATE DURING THE PANDEMIC
STUDENTS IN OUR MOST ISOLATED
REGIONS STRUGGLED THE MOST TO
ACHIEVE ACCESS OUR EDUCATORS
ADMINISTRATORS FAMILIES AND
STUDENTS NEED FULL ACCESS TO
THE INTERNET TO ENSURE THE
STABILITY TO A THRIVING ECONOMY
AND SB FIVE FIVE SIX WILL
DEPLOY BROADBAND THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. TIME IS OUR ATTACHMENTS
TO ADDRESS OUR BARRIERS TO
DEPLOYMENT AND TO EXPAND
SERVICES THROUGHOUT OUR STATE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A YES VOTE
ON THIS CRITICALLY NEEDED
INFRASTRUCTURE EXACT INTO
LEGISLATION THANK YOU THANK YOU
EXACTLY TWO MINUTES- MR REYES.
C. GOOD AFTERNOON. MR CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
ROOM EDDIE RAY S. WITH THE RISE
I'M HERE TO EXPRESS OUR STE SO.
ALONG WITH- CT- AND OVER THIRTY
THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS WHO HAVE
REGISTERED THEIR SUPPORT ONLINE
FOR THIS CRITICALLY NEEDED
BILL. TO EXPAND FIVE G. HIGH
SPEED RELIABLE WIRELESS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA EVERYONE ASKS WHAT
THE KILLER APP IS GOING TO BE
WITH FIVE G. AND BECAUSE ITS
WIRELESS PEOPLE ASSUME MOBILE
BUT THE KILLER APP IS GOING TO
BE FIXED WIRELESS SOLUTIONS.
ALONG WITH A NUMBER OF
ENTERPRISE APPLICATIONS RELATED
TO TELEHEALTH DISTANCE LEARNING
SMART CITIES TRAFFIC CONTROL
AND WHATNOT. BUT IT'S ALL ABOUT
BROADBAND IN THIS YEAR OF
BROADBAND. SENATOR GONZALEZ-
AND THE PRIOR SPEAKER TALKED A
LOT ABOUT WHAT THIS BILL DOES
LET ME SPEND A FEW MOMENTS TO
EXPLAIN WHAT IT DOES NOT DO.
THIS BILL BILL DOES NOT TAKE
AWAY ANY LOCAL AUTHORITY OVER.
SAFETY OR AESTHETICS VERY
CLEARLY IN THE BILL SAYS THAT-
LOCAL CONTROL IS PRESERVED FOR
REASONABLE AESTHETIC AND SAFETY
STANDARDS. THE BILL CONTAINS A
GRANDFATHERING CLAUSE THAT GOES
BEYOND AND IS MORE FAVORABLE TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS THAN WHAT IS
IN THE FCC ORDER. IT PRESERVES
EXISTING AGREEMENTS AN EXISTING
DEPLOYMENTS AND TAKES EFFECT
ONCE THIS BILL. **** THIS BILL
WHILE IT DOES IT GOES A LONG
WAY FOR SMALL CELLS IS NOT A
SILVER BULLET AND TOGETHER WITH
THE GOVERNOR SEVEN BILLION
DOLLAR BROADBAND PROPOSAL WHICH
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT INCLUDING
THE MIDDLE MILE COMPONENT. AND
THE OTHER PIECE OF THE
LEGISLATURE LEGISLATION GOING
THROUGH WILL BE IN ALL OF THE
ABOVE APPROACH TO BROADBAND
THAT WE DESPERATELY NEED. AND I
STAND READY TO ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS THAT CHAIR
YOU WOULD LIKE ME TO ADDRESS
RESPECTFULLY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MR REYES AND I'M GONNA TAKE
A QUICK BREAK HERE TO-
ESTABLISH A QUORUM- MANTA K.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SANTIAGO
HERE SANTIAGO HERE PATTERSON.
BOERNER HORVATH RYAN BRAND HERE
BENNETT BENNETT HERE DAVIES.
DAVIS HERE EDUARDO GARCIA
HOLDEN LOW QUICK SILVA.
QUIKSILVER HERE RODRIGUEZ
VALLADARES BUILDERS HERE WEBER.
WEBER HERE AT SEVEN. THANK YOU
AND WE'RE GONNA PROCEED TO THE
PRO TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION AGAIN WILL BE FOUR
MINUTES NOT GIVE A GENTLE TUG
AFTER TWO MINUTES THE FIRST
PERSON- MISTER STAN- SANTOS IS
THE FIRST FOLLOWED BY MISTER
MAYOR- JAMES BUT CITY LINGLE
IT- MISTER SANTOS HE AVAILABLE.
YES SIR. YOU MAY PROCEED IN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I BEGIN.
YES SIR THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MANY COMMITTEE CHAIRED MEMBERS
I'M STANCE OFFICE REPRESENTING
THE COMMUNICATIONS WORKERS OF
AMERICA DISTRICT NINE. ON
BEHALF OF THOUSANDS OF
COMMUNICATIONS WORKERS IN
CALIFORNIA WE OPPOSE SB FIVE
FIVE SIX. THIS BILL CONTAINS
OVERLY STRICT TIME LINES AND
LIMITS THE ABILITY OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO PERFORM DUE
DILIGENCE IN THE REVIEW OF
PERMIT APPLICATIONS AND FEES.
IT'S A GIVEAWAY OF PUBLIC
RESOURCES AND FAVORS PROFITS
OVER SAFETY. YOU HAVE A STUDY
THE PERMIT PROCESS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY AND FOUND THAT ZERO
REVIEWS CRUCIAL FOR SAFETY
SHORTEN TIMELINES UNDER SB FIVE
BY SIX TIE THE HANDS OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AND WORSEN SAFETY
CONDITIONS. ESPECIALLY THE LACK
OF ASSURANCES THAT
INSTALLATIONS ARE CONDUCTED BY
PROFESSIONALLY TRAINED WORKERS
NOT BY SUBCONTRACTORS WHO MAIN
DANGER THE PUBLIC AND WORKERS
IN THE RIGHT WAY. NOTHING IN SB
FIVE FIVE SIX REQUIRES THE USE
OF A PROFESSIONALLY TRAINED
WORK FORCE. CW A. CONTRIBUTED
TO A RECENT REPORT BY THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
TELECOMMUNICATIONS OFFICERS AND
ADVISORS. THAT DETAILS MULTIPLE
PROBLEMS WITH APPLICATION
TIMELINES AND FEES LIKE THOSE
NASTY FIVE FIVE SIX. FOUR OUT
OF FIVE LOCAL GOVERNMENT SAID
THAT PROVIDERS REGULARLY SUBMIT
INCOMPLETE APPLICATIONS.
NOTHING IN THIS BILL ADDRESSES
THEIR FAILURE TO COMPLY WITH
THE LAW BUT TO STRENGTHENING
PENALTIES FOR NON COMPLIANCE.
OVER 50% OF LOCAL RESPONDENTS
REPORT THAT TELECOMMUNICATIONS
DOLLARS DAMAGE AND OR FAILED TO
PROPERLY RESTORE PUBLIC
PROPERTY WITH LOCAL TAXPAYERS
OFTEN PICKING UP THE TAB. WE
WILL CONTINUE TO SEE INCIDENTS
LIKE THE UNLICENSED CONTRACTOR
IN SAN FRANCISCO WHO CUT THE
GAS LINE EXPLOSION. I WORK IN
BURIED IN AERIAL CONSTRUCTION
OF FIBER AND COPPER PLANT WE
ALREADY DEAL WITH TRAFFIC
CONTROL STEPS TO PUBLIC SAFETY
WITH MINIMUM OBSTACLES IMPOSED
BY LOCAL GOVERNMENT. IF
ANYTHING THERE ARE NOT
SUFFICIENT TRAINED SAFETY SET
UP PERSONNEL THIS BILL WILL
FORCE THE RAMP UP OF THAT
RESOURCES WHICH IS ALREADY
LACKING. WE URGE YOU TO VOTE NO
ON SB FIVE FIVE SIX. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER SANTOS. MISTER
MAYOR. MR COMMITTEE CHAIR AND
MEMBERS TRANSPORTATION CITY
RECORDS- IS NOT ABOUT. WHAT
HASN'T BEEN DONE BECAUSE THE
INTERNET ACCESS IT'S BEEN
AROUND FOR ABOUT TWENTY FIVE
YEARS SO THEN WHY ARE THERE
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES AT THIS
POINT AND NOW WHY DO WE HAVE TO
GIVE AWAY CITIES LOCAL CONTROL
OF THE IMPLEMENTATION OF FIVE
G. WE DIDN'T WAIT THE CITY OF
INGLEWOOD. WHEN I TOOK OFFICE
ELEVEN YEARS AGO. EVERY STREET
THAT WE RESURFACED AND WE'VE
DONE A LOT OF THEM RELATED
FIBER OPTIC CONDUIT TO THE
TEACHER. OKAY WHEN WE CHOSE TO.
WE COULD PROVIDE OUR OWN SPEED.
IN OUR CITY IS NOW COMPLETELY
RANG AND WE'RE IN AN RRSP
REPORTED TO PROVIDE. BROADBAND
ACCESS AT THE CITY LOCAL LEVEL
ALSO. AS A MEMBER OF A MATURE
METRO I WAS ABLE TO GET
MITCHELL TO GIVE THE SOUTH BAY
CITIES. EIGHTY FOUR POINT FIVE
BILLION DOLLAR GRANT TO SAME
THING FOR THE SOUTH BAY AND
THAT SYSTEM IS UP AND RUNNING
OURS WILL BE. UP AND RUNNING
PROBABLY IN THE NEXT SIX MONTHS.
WE WANTED TO. PARTNER WITH A
MAJOR KERRIER. AND ALLOW THEM
TO USE OUR CURRENT DO IT SO
THEY WOULD HAVE TO DIG UP OUR
STREETS TEMPERAMENT BY G. G. NO
WHAT. THEY DIDN'T WANT TO SEE
WHAT IT WAS WORTH. AND SO TO.
DO THIS WHAT YOU'RE DOING IS
CIRCUMVENTING THE ASPIRATIONS
AND BILL OF CITIES THROUGHOUT
THE STATE THAT ARE COMMITTED TO
WORKING TOGETHER TO CLOSE THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE ESPECIALLY IN
OUR UNSERVED AND UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES WE MUST WORK NOW
TO CONNECT CONNECT THE TWO
POINT THREE MILLION
CALIFORNIANS THAT HAVE NO
MEANINGFUL ACCESS TO THE
INTERNET FOR THE SAME TIME
LAYING THE GROUNDWORK FOR
AFFORDABILITY AND THAT I
HAVEN'T HEARD ANYTHING ABOUT
THE SPORT UNTIL THE FOR. LOW
INCOME FAMILIES AND CHOICE FOR
THE FIFTEEN POINT FOUR MILLION
MORE WHO LIVE IN THE AREA
RUNNING OUT OF TIME AFTERWARDS
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT THEY THINK
ANYONE WOULD PICK ABOUT CLOTHES
UP CLOSE IT UP I THINK THIS IS
A POWER GRAB BY THE S. P.
SYSTEM FIFTEEN YEARS PROVIDING
SERVICE HERE'S OUR PROFITS
SUGGEST ANY NOR COMMUNITIES
THAT NEED IT THE MOST THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU MUCH
APPRECIATE ALL YOUR COMMENTS
WILL NOW MOVE THE PUBLIC
COMMENTS- IN OPPOSITION- AND I
REMIND YOU NAME ORGANIZATION
AND POSITION ONLY- WE'RE GONNA
START OFF WITH THE CHAMBER AND
I WILL DO BOTH SUPPORT.
OPPOSITION JUST TO MOVE THIS
AND A LITTLE BIT QUICKER- WE'LL
START OFF WITH THE CHAMBER.
NAME POSITION ONLY THAT
ORGANIZATIONS ARE. GOOD
AFTERNOON JOHANNA FINNEY FROM
THE NEVADA COUNTY
TELECOMMUNICATIONS PUBLIC
WORKING GROUP WE OPPOSE SB FIVE
FIVE SIX THANK YOU VERY MUCH. I
BELIEVE OF ONE MORE MY NAME IS
PAUL MCGANN FROM A GROUP OF
THREE PLUS MILLION CALIFORNIANS
WHO KNOW THE CODE NINETEEN
EXCUSES SHOULD NOT BE USED TO
BRING BACK THE NEIGHBORHOOD
ORGANIZATION. FIVE FIVE. WE'RE
AND- THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANY
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT OPPOSITION
WITNESSES AT THE REMOTE- THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY ROOM.
UNMASTERED COMMITTEE AND
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO JUST
GIVE ME A MINUTE OR TWO THERE'S
A BIT OF TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES
WITH THE TELEPHONE LINE THAT
I'VE BEEN ADVISED UP SO GIVE IT
A MINUTE OR TWO SO THEY CAN- RE
RESETTING MAYBE. NOT THE RIGHT
WORD BUT I'LL USE IT TO
RESETTING SO THEY CAN GET THE
WITNESSES ON THE PHONE TO JUST
BEAR WITH ME FOR ABOUT A MINUTE
OR TWO. I APOLOGIZE. IN THE
MEANTIME I'LL TAKE THAT TIME
TO- TO ASK FOR SECONDS A
FLORIDA FIRST AND IN MOTION ON
THE CONSENT FILE. WE'RE THE
FIRST ON THE CONSENT FILE. IS
DAVIS IN THIS- WEBER ON THE
CONSENT FILED MOTIONS FOR THE
SECOND- MAN OF SECRETARY IF YOU
COULD PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ITEM NUMBER FIVE SB THREE NINE
FOR THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED
APPROPRIATIONS SANTIAGO HI
SANTIAGO AYE PATTERSON.
BOERNER HORVATH BRIAN BRENT HI
BENNETT DAVIES DAVIES I EDUARDO
GARCIA HOLDEN LOW QUICK SILVA.
QUICK SILVA AYE RODRIGUEZ
VALLADARES. VOTERS AYE WEBER.
WEBER HI. I SIX NO ZERO. THANK
YOU FOR. GIVE ME ONE MORE
MINUTE WORK WITHIN THE SYSTEM.
THANK YOU MEMBERS IN AND THE
PUBLIC JUST GIVE IT ANOTHER
SECOND I APOLOGIZE.
MODERATOR I
BELIEVE YOU'RE UP- IF WE CAN GO
TO LEGALIZE CAPITALIZE FOR ANY
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT OPPOSITION
WITNESSES I REMIND YOU STATE
YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION AND
POSITION ONLY. TO STATE YOUR
POSITION ON THIS BILL SB FIVE
FIVE SIX AND YOU PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD.
THROW CIRCLE AND NOT Q. MISTER
CHAIR WE'LL START WITH. ONE
FORTY SEVEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS ROCKS
HANDLED REPRESENTING THE
WIRELESS INFRASTRUCTURE
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL THANK YOU. LINE. ONE FORTY
FOUR. GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAR THIS IS RYAN ELAINE WITH
THE CALIFORNIA RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. TWENTY IS YOUR PHONE ON
MUTE. HELLO MY NAME IS JOHN
CARLA RUBIO WITH THE VALLEY
INDUSTRY AND COMMERCE
ASSOCIATION AND WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT SENATE BILL FIVE FIVE
SIX. NEXT WE HAVE LINE NINETY
TWO. AFTER NEARLY ANY TARGET ON
BEHALF OF TECH THAT IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
ONE SIXTY ONE. GOOD AFTERNOON
JUSTIN HIGHER ON BEHALF OF THE
SILICON VALLEY LEADERSHIP GROUP
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANK YOU. ONE SEVENTY TWO.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS CAROLINE
THE NUMBERS WITH THE SEASON
PETERSON WEBER WITH T. MOBILE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
FINAL. ONE TEN. ONE ONE NO THEY
REMOVE THEMSELVES OVER THE LINE
ONE TWENTY EIGHT. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE
MEMBERS JOHN THE CLAY ABOUT THE
CITY BEEN COMMITTED OPPOSITION
TO SB FIVE FIVE SIX THANK YOU.
BLIND'S SEVENTY FOUR. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS YVONNE
NELSON- ON BEHALF OF
COMMUNICATION WORKERS OF
AMERICA DISTRICT NINE AND WE'RE
STRONG BUT- OPPOSITION TO SB.
FIVE FIVE. NINE ONE TWENTY
SEVEN. GOOD AFTERNOON TRACY
RIGHT WITH THE WORLD CONNECT
SAYS THE CALIFORNIA AND ALSO ON
BEHALF OF THE REPEATED
SUFFICIENT COUNTIES AND URBAN
COUNTY OF CALIFORNIA IN
OPPOSITION 25% THANK YOU. ONE
EIGHTEEN. ONE ONE EIGHT BECAUSE
YOUR PHONE ON MUTE. AFTER DODD
ALLIANCE NURSES FOR A HEALTHY
ENVIRONMENT IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL. NINE FIFTY FOUR.
MELISSA SMITH CALIFORNIA
PERFECT TECHNOLOGY WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE SB. FIVE THOUSAND. ONE
FIFTY FIVE. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CARE OF OFF ON
BEHALF OF THE TOWN OF TRUCKEE
AND THE CITIES OF STOCKTON AND
GLENDALE ALL IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL. THANK YOU. ONE
SEVENTY ONE. HELLO HI CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE CHANTE
CATHOLIC LAWSON ACCESS HUMBOLDT
IN EUREKA SUPPORT COMMUNITY
ACCESS- AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL SB FIVE FIVE SIX.
THANK YOU. ONE THIRTEEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON THE CARD NUMBER KAREN
LAYING ON BEHALF OF MAYOR
LONDON BREED IN OPPOSITION THE
FINAL COUNTERPRODUCTIVE RIDERS
WITH CONTENT THANK YOU. ONE
SIXTY TWO. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE BALKANS OFFICE ON THE
UP THE CITIES OF BELLFLOWER
CHINO EL GROW FAIRFIELD LUMBER
OUT OF LAKE WITH NORWALK
PALMDALE RANCHO CORDOVA RANCHO
CUCAMONGA REDDING SANTA CLARITA
SIGNAL HILL THOUSAND OAKS IN
TORRANCE ALL IN RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION. ONE SIXTY FIVE.
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU TERM
MEMBERS ANTHONY TOWN HALL WITH
THE CALIFORNIA SPECIAL
DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. Y. AND.
ONE OH FIVE. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS PATRICIA BURN ON AND
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE LOS
ANGELES AREA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE IN STRONG SUPPORT SB
FIVE I THINK THANK YOU. ONE
FORTY EIGHT. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS J. LIKE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
MUNICIPAL UTILITIES ASSOCIATION
THOSE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED TO SB FIVE FIVE
SIX. FIFTY EIGHT. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME'S ANTHONY
TESTER WITH THE COMMUNICATIONS
WORKERS OF AMERICA LOCAL NINETY
FIVE JAMMED IN STRONG
OPPOSITION OF FIVE FIVE SIX.
ONE FIFTY THREE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS THIS IS
JONATHAN ERA BELL ON BEHALF OF
CTIA THE TRADE ASSOCIATION FOR
THE WIRELESS INDUSTRY IN STRONG
SUPPORT. ONE SIXTEEN. YOUR
CURRENT WILL BE AT TO LEAVE
SHOP ON THE CAPITAL CITY OF LOS
ANGELES MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL ALSO
WOULD NEED FOR THE CITY OF
SANTA MONICA AND BEVERLY HILLS
THANK YOU. VERY LINE. ONE
TWENTY SIX YEAH. THE MAKING AN
I THE DIRECTOR OF THE SANTA
BARBARA BY THERAPY INSTITUTE-
OPPOSE SB. FIVE FIVE SIX. WELL
LINE. SIXTY EIGHT. RIGHT HI
THERE- FOR RADIATION FREE
COMMUNITY .ORG THE PEOPLE'S
INITIATIVE FOUNDATION AMERICAN
ASSOCIATION FOR CELLPHONE
SAFETY AND CITIZENS WHO HAVE
BEEN GIVEN CANCER OR OTHERWISE
PHYSICALLY HARMED BY BEING
FORCED TO LIVE TOO CLOSE TO
WIRELESS TRANSMITTERS WE ALL
STRONGLY OPPOSE. LINE FIFTY.
CURRENTS RIDER FROM THE CITY OF
ENCINITAS STRONGLY OPPOSED. ONE
FIFTY ONE. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS KURT BLACKBURN CALLING
ON BEHALF OF THE CITIES OF
LOCKING OUT APPOINTMENTS AND L.
CENTRO IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU.
ONE EIGHTY ONE. GOOD AFTERNOON
AS CHAIR MEMBERS DAVID NELSON
DIRECTOR POLICY FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ASIAN PACIFIC
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE CALLING IN
WITH STRONG SUPPORT OF SB FIVE
FIVE SIX. ONE OH THREE. JANET
BEALES COMMUNICATION WORKERS OF
AMERICA. NINE FIVE EIGHT EIGHT.
CALLING IN OPPOSITION. OF SB
FIVE FIVE SIX. ONE EIGHTY TWO.
HELLO MY NAME IS SYDNEY CRACKS
ON BEHALF OF HUNDREDS OF
RESIDENTS WITH SAFETY CHECK FOR
SANTA ROSA WE STRONGLY OPPOSE
SB FIVE FIVE SIX THANK YOU. ONE
FORTY NINE. GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS ROGER
DICKINSON OF THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMISSION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. SIXTEEN SIX
ZERO. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
NUMBER NINETEEN OF THE CARICOM
BEHALF OF CALLING THE UTILITY
REFORM NETWORK IN OPPOSITION.
ONE SEVENTY FOUR. HELLO CAN YOU
HEAR ME ONE SEVENTY FOUR. YES.
YOUR AVAILABLE ROCK VALLEY IN
THE STATE COUNCIL IN STRONG
OPPOSITION. FOUR FIVE FIVE SIX.
THANK YOU. NINE ONE SIXTY
THREE. GERMAN SANTIAGO AND
MEMBERS OF MICHAEL'S ARCA-
PUBLIKU IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
FIVE FIVE SIX THANK YOU. FORTY
FOUR. YES GOOD AFTERNOON JODY
NELSON A CO FOUNDER OF
CALIFORNIANS A TECHNOLOGY WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB FIVE FIVE
SIX. ONE THIRTY EIGHT. HI THIS
IS WHEN HE RECEIVED A
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL IN SUPPORT
CAPITEC. EIGHTY FOUR. HI KAREN
OBEYED WITH LOCAL
COMMUNICATIONS EMPLOYEES
AGAINST GIVING SAFETY CONTROL
TO CORPORATE PROFITS PETALUMA
CAN GROW CINNAMIC COUNTY IN
KHATAMI CALIFORNIA THANK YOU.
NINE SIX NINE THREE REPORT
THANK YOU NINE SIXTY THREE.
WHAT STOP TURNING COMMUNICATION
WORKERS OF AMERICA DISTRICT
NINE IN STRONG OPPOSITION OF SB
FIVE FIVE SIX. NINETY EIGHT.
THE COPELAND FROM FALLING ON
THE BEACH AND STRONG OPPOSITION
OF THAT THE FACT THAT. ONE OH
NINE. SURE YOU KNOW WESTERN WAY
COMMUNICATION WORKERS OF
AMERICA LOCAL NINETY FOUR IN
STRONG OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE
FIVE SIX. NINE ONE ALL FOR.
VICKY SIEVERS REPRESENTING THE
EMF SAFETY NETWORK WITH MEMBERS
ACROSS CALIFORNIA AND BEYOND IN
STRONG OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
LINE. ONE TWENTY ONE. ONE TWO
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN OKAY THIS
IS- STEPHANIE THOMAS- THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS- I'M A CO
FOUNDER OF WIRELESS RADIATION
EDUCATION A DEFENSE IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO SENATE BILL FIVE
FIFTY SIX. EIGHTY NINE BOB GOOD
AFTERNOON ASSEMBLYMEMBERS KIM
HAN TO HEAD THE TUTORING
SERVICES CENTER ITSELF WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB FIVE FIFTY
SIX THANK YOU. ONE FORTY ONE.
HI MY NAME IS JEFF BIRNBAUM
FROM TABASCO CALIFORNIA I
STRONGLY OPPOSED SB. FIVE FIVE
SIX. ONE FIFTY NINE. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF CARLSBAD CORONA DEL
MAR REDWOOD CITY AND FOSTER
CITY THIS IS SHERIN EVAN FELKER
AND OPPOSITION TO. THANK YOU.
FIFTY NINE. THIS IS LESLIE ONE
STOCK I REPRESENT SAFETY
TECHNOLOGY FOR SANTA BARBARA
COUNTY. SANTA BARBARA GREEN
SISTERS SWEET WATER
COLLABORATIVE AND SUMANA S.
RETREAT AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE.
SIX THANK YOU SIXTY TWO. JEAN
RASH REPRESENTING THE MONTEREY
VISTA NEIGHBORHOOD ASSOCIATION
OF THIRTEEN HUNDRED HOMES IN
STRONG OPPOSITION TO SB. FIVE
FIVE SIX. ONE FIFTY THREE.
HELLO MY NAME IS A LAWYER SO
THE BAR NINE MAMA WITH LOCAL
NINE FOUR TWO ONE M.
SACRAMENTAL COMMUNICATION
WORKERS OF AMERICA AND WE ARE
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO SP FIVE
FIVE SIX. SIXTY SEVEN. HELLO MY
NAME IS MARTIN MILLER I'M WITH
CITIZENS FOR SAFE TECHNOLOGY IN
CINEMA COUNTY- I LIVE IN
WINDSOR CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY
OPPOSED SB FIVE FIVE SIX. ONE
TWELVE. HI MY NAME FERRAMENTA
MEMBER OF UNITED EDUCATORS OF
SAN FRANCISCO IN WRITING A
PRIVATE CAPACITY I STRONGLY
OPPOSED SB FIVE FIVE SIX. ONE
THIRTY TWO. THANK YOU MATT
STOPPER ON BEHALF OF THE SANTA
MONICA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE IN
SUPPORT. SEVENTY TWO. HI LARRY
FILIPPINI EXCEPT THE ON THE
BOARD OF THE BREAK A BAY AREA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE A COASTAL
AREA WITH VERY POOR
CONNECTIVITY AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE SENATE BILL FIVE FIVE
SIX THANK YOU. EIGHTY FIVE.
THANK YOU MEMBERS AND SHARE- MY
NAME IS ROBERT ERIN
REPRESENTING CHILDREN WORLDWIDE
AND LAKE TAHOE FOR SAFE FIBER
OPTIC TECHNOLOGY WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL FIVE FIVE SIX
THANK YOU. SEVENTY SEVEN. HI MY
NAME IS ANDREA NAMASTE AND
REPRESENTING FIVE G. FREE
CALIFORNIA WITH NUMBERS UP AND
DOWN THE STATE WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE SB FIVE FIVE SIX. ONE
FIFTY FOUR. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS
IS CHERYL MATTHEWS ON THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR
CALIFORNIA FOR SAFE TECHNOLOGY
AND I AM CALLING IN ON BEHALF
OF MAYOR TONKA AND THE CITY
COUNCIL FOR LOS ALTOS HILLS WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB FIVE FIVE
SIX THANK YOU. SIXTY NINE. THIS
IS JONATHAN COCKEREL LIVING
HERE LAKE CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY
OPPOSED SB FIVE FIVE SIX THANK
YOU. ONE TWO THREE YES- MY NAME
IS DONE MAY I FEEL VERY VERY
STRONGLY OPPOSE FIVE FIVE SIX
WHAT WE WANT IS WHY YOUR EX
BROADBANDWHICH IS FASTER SAFER
MUCH HEALTHIER ENERGY EFFICIENT
AND CYBER SECURE ONLY ALREADY
KNOWS THAT TWO G. THREE G. AND
FOUR G. CAUSES BIOLOGICAL HOT
BUT THE WORD IS A SIMPLICITY
ONLY NAME ORGANIZATION.
POSITION ONLY MODERATE TO THE
NEXT PERSON PLEASE. LINE. SIX
SEVEN. ONE SIX SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. WE'LL GO TO A FIFTY
TWO. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
CLEO CABRAL THE CW A LOCAL NINE
FOUR ZERO EIGHT AND WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE SB FIVE FIVE SIX THANK
YOU. NINETY ONE. NINE NINE ONE
ARE YOU IN NEED. IN ORDER ONE
OH SEVEN. HELLO I'M DIANE CRAIG
IN BUELLTON CALIFORNIA I
STRONGLY OPPOSED SB FIVE FIVE
SIX THANK YOU. SIXTY ONE. YEAH
WE BURKE REPRESENTING AMERICANS
FOR RESPONSIBLE TECHNOLOGY IN
STRONG OPPOSITION TO SB FIVE
FIVE SIX THANK YOU. ONE THIRTY
THREE. THANKS. FOR ONE THREE
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU THIS IS JOANNE. FROM
SCRATCH VALLEY I AM STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO S. B. SPY TRIED
PLANET PERCENT FIVE FIVE SIX.
BERMAN FIFTY FIVE. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHRIS BEAUCHAMP WITH
COMMUNICATION WORKERS OF
AMERICA LOCAL NINETY FIVE
ELEVEN AND WE HAVE VEHEMENTLY
OPPOSE I THANK SIX THANK YOU.
SEVENTY FIVE. CARLA COMBO
THIRTIES WITH THE WA NINETY
FOUR THIRTEEN AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THE BILL. FORTY EIGHT.
YEAH JOHNSON C. W. A. NINE
THOUSAND THREE WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE SB FIVE FIVE SIX THANK
YOU. SIXTY FOUR. HI THE CARTER
MEDINA WITH ORANGE COUNTY
BUSINESS COUNCIL AND STRONG
SUPPORT SB FIVE FIVE SIX THANK
YOU. ONE HUNDRED. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS JUST YOUR RUN
OF THE COMMUNICATION WORKERS OF
AMERICA AND RADIATION FREE
NEIGHBORHOODS AND SCHOOLS
JULISSA IN STRONG OPPOSITION SB
FIVE FIVE SIX. ONE OH ONE
DOCTORS SAY UNDER ROTH
REPRESENTING HYPERSENSITIVE
DISABLED PEOPLE WHO NEED TO OPT
OUT DESPERATELY MISSION IN
POSITION ONLY NAME
ORGANIZATIONS ONLY MODERATE
NEXT PERSON. ONE NINETY TWO.
REALMETER THIS IS CHRIS WILSON
WITH A LOT ABOUT THE COUNTY
BUSINESS FEDERATION WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB FIVE FIVE
SIX THANK YOU SO MUCH. ONE
EIGHTY SEVEN. JERRY MEMBERS
MADE SO LOVE ON BEHALF OF CROWN
CASTLE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
BILL THANK YOU. ONE NINETY.
HELLO MY NAME IS KERRY TOPPER I
MEAN AND THEN SEE CALIFORNIA
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE SB I
THANK THANK THANK YOU. ONE
THIRTY NINE. MY NAME IS
CHARLENE HOPI A RESIDENT OF LOS
ANGELES COUNTY CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSED SB FIVE FIVE
SIX. ONE EIGHTY EIGHT. MY NAME
IS SERRA JACOBSON I'M A
CONSTITUENT AND ANTHONY THE
DISTRICT SEVENTY SIX I'M
CALLING IN OPPOSITION TO SB
FIVE FIVE SIX. THANK YOU.
NINETY NINE. YES THIS IS DAVID
GRIND- I REPRESENT STOP FIVE G.
CARLSBAD AND ALL THE CHILDREN
AND WE COMPLETELY NAME
ORGANIZATION OF HIS OWN ONLY.
THANK YOU. ONE NINETY FOUR.
THIS IS JENNY MILLER WITH
TOWARDS AN INTERNET FOR LIVING
BEINGS AND WE ARE STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO SB FIVE FIVE SIX DUE
TO EXTREME NAME ORGANIZATION A
POSITION ONLY THANK YOU. ONE
NINETY FIVE. HELLO THIS IS
LARRY ORTEGA WITH COMMUNITY
UNION AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE.
FIVE FIVE SIX. ONE SIX SEVEN.
HELLO CONSTANCE ANDERSON MEMBER
OF WIRED SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
THE POPULATE PART OF THE
POPULATION SUFFER FROM
DEBILITATING NAME ORGANIZATION
AND POSITIONALLY WELL BE FORCED
OUT OF THEIR HOME NAME
ORGANIZATION POSITION ONLY
MODERATE GO TO NEXT PERSON
PLEASE. SEVENTY ONE. HELLO MY
NAME IS HELEN SEARS I LIVE IN
MENDOCINO I AM VERY VERY
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO SB FIVE
FIVE SIX. NINETY ONE. MY NINE
ONE ARE YOU ON MUTE. GO. TO TWO
OH FIVE. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS AND THE- DEAL THOMAS I'M
CALLING FROM BASIC KNOWLEDGE
REPORT ON THE BARBARA AND I
REPRESENTS FOUR HUNDRED
RESIDENTS WERE STRONGLY OPPOSED
TO SB FIVE FIVE SIX THANK YOU.
NINE TWO OH SIX. HI THIS IS
JENNIFER LOW PORTER WITH STAGE
TECHNOLOGY FOR SANTA ROSA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE. THIS HARMFUL
SB. FIVE FIVE SIX. NO FURTHER
LINES IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME. I
THINK IT'S MODERATOR NOW WE GO
TO ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. THIS BOERNER HORVATH.
WELL BY THE TIME I MOVE MY MASS
THEREFORE BACK THANK YOU- YES
SO I HAD TO TWO QUESTIONS- FOR
THE AUTHOR AT OR THE SPONSOR
CAN YOU PLEASE WALK ME THROUGH
THE PERMITTING PROCESS
SPECIFICALLY WHAT ARE THE
GROUNDS FOR REASONABLE DOUBT
AND I'LL FROM A LOCAL
GOVERNMENT FOR A PERMIT AND
ALSO WHAT DESIGN RECEIVING
REVIEW STANDARDS WHAT A CITY BE
ABLE TO USE BECAUSE I THINK
THAT IS BOTH IN THE BILL AND WE
HEARD A LOT OF OPPOSITION FOR
THE CITIES I KNOW THE AUTHOR
HAS WORKED QUITE EXTENSIVELY.
TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE IS A
DESIGN REVIEW BUT IF IT'S-
EITHER THE OFFICE OF THE
PRESENTER OR THE SPONSORS COULD
WALK US THROUGH WHAT THE
PROCESS LOOKS LIKE I THINK THAT
WOULD GIVE SOME ASSURANCE TO
OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENT SURE AND
THEN SECOND QUESTION MEDICINE
OR HOW WOULD YOU PREFER THAT-
MISTER CHAIR IF I CAN DEFER. TO
MISTER RAY IS THAT WOULD BE
GREAT THANKS REYES. HELLO
MISTER CHAIR YOU SENATOR THANK
YOU. MEMBER **** BATH OF YOUR
FOR YOUR QUESTION. SO THE BILL
AS YOU SAY DOES PRESERVE ALL
LOCAL CONTROL ALL REASONABLE
AESTHETIC AND SAFETY STANDARDS.
THE BILL DOES NOT MICROMANAGE-
WHAT THOSE ARE AND WHAT IS THE
FCC- THE ONLY LIMITATION ON
THAT. IS THAT IT CANNOT RESULT
IN A DENIAL OF SERVICE SO YOU
CAN'T MAKE THE STANDARD SO
HIGH. THAT IT IT IT MAKES IT
INFEASIBLE ARE IMPOSSIBLE TO
DEPLOY FIVE G. IN THE CITY. THE
FIRST FIVE QUESTIONS THE SECOND
QUESTION. YES SO THE SECOND
QUESTION IF THE CITY DETERMINED
AND IS VERY SPECIFIC I JUST GO
HOME WITH MY CITY ABOUT THIS
THAT THE SIGNAL- THAT A
SIGNALED INTERSECTION AND THEY
WANT TO PUT A SMALL SO ON THE
SIGNALED INTERSECTION MY CITIES
PARTICULARLY CONCERNED THAT-
THAT THE PROVIDER WOULD REPLACE
THE SIGNAL WITH ONE THAT
DOESN'T MATCH OTHER SIGNALS IN
THE CITY. COULD YOU COMMENT ON
THAT IN CASE THE SIGNAL CANNOT
BEAR THE WEIGHT OF THE SMALL
SELF IS THAT A GROUNDS FOR
DENIAL OR WHAT IS CITY HAVE
PURVIEW TO DESIGN THE NEW
SIGNALIZED INTERSECTION HOLES
THAT NEED TO GO UP. WITH THE
PERMISSION OF THE CHAIR. I
THINK THE ANSWER BROADLY IS
YES- THERE'S BROAD DISCRETION
AGAIN AGAIN IT. AS LONG AS IT'S
NOT COERCIVE BUT WHAT TEMP TECH
WHAT HAPPENS DURING THIS MAKE
READY PROCESS AND THE BILL. IS
THAT YOU ASK FOR PERMISSION TO
GO UP ON THE POLE THEY CAN SAY
YES OR NO BASED ON A
REASONABLE. BASIS AND THEN THEY
TELL YOU IF THERE'S ANY
FOUNDATION WORK OR ANY MAKE
READY WORK OR WHATEVER THAT
NEEDS TO HAPPEN. THAT IS ALL ON
THE PROVIDER IT'S COSTS TO DO.
SO IF ONE OF THOSE IS TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE NEW LET'S SAY WE
DO HAVE TO REPLACE THE
FOUNDATION AND THE YOU WANT TO
MAKE THE TRAFFIC SIGNAL. LIGHT
LIKE OTHERS THAT'S IT THAT'S
NOT A PROBLEM. THANK YOU ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS- FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND STATUS.
COULD YOU PLEASE LET ME KNOW-
WHAT THE PROCEDURES IF PERHAPS
PROVIDER DOESN'T THINK THAT THE
REQUEST IS- YOU DON'T
PERMISSIBLE WHAT HAPPENS A
REASONABLE. IS THAT IT IS JUST
JUST BECAUSE SOMEBODY ELSE HAS
A HAND UP AND OUT THERE YOUR
REFER YOU'RE ASKING MR REYES
RIGHT OKAY SO I HAVE THE
APPROPRIATE PERSON RESPONSE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER- SO. I
TYPICALLY THE PROVIDERS TRY TO
WORK IT OUT WITH THE CITY RIGHT
THERE'S- LOTS OF POLLS.
AVAILABLE STREET LIGHT POLES
TRAFFIC SIGNAL POLES UTILITY
POLES. THOSE ARE ALL AVAILABLE
SOURCES TO ATTACH TO WIRELESS
INFRASTRUCTURE SO IF THERE'S A
PARTICULAR POLL THAT IS- IN
FEASIBLE TO DEPLOY ON. THEN YOU
CAN CHOOSE THE NEXT BEST FULL.
DID DID I ANSWER YOUR QUESTION
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. NO I'M I'M I'M
JUST YOU KNOW IT SO IF YOU WERE
A PROVIDER IN THE CITY SAYS YOU
KNOW WHAT. WE DON'T WANT THIS
THIS IS IT THIS IS WHAT WE WANT
AND IT'S NOT BEING RECEPTACLE-
WHAT IS THE RESPONSE OF ME DOES
IT CODEWHERE DOES IT GO IF YOU
GUYS CAN'T MEET. OUR ON- IF IT
IS A GENUINE DISPUTE THAT WE-
SEE I'D ION YEAH. THEN YOU KNOW
ARE ONLY THE PROVIDERS ONLY
RECOURSE WOULD BE TO YOU KNOW
TAKE IT TO. THE COURT AND SAY.
THAT THIS CITIES. RULES ARE SO
STRINGENT THAT THEY EFFECTIVELY
DENY. THE ABILITY TO PROVIDE
FIVE G. IN THAT CITY. BUT
THAT'S- THAT'S A VERY EXTREME
CASES TYPICALLY. THE PROVIDER
WORKS IT OUT WITH THE CITY OF
DAY. THE CITY ADOPTS THEIR OWN
DESIGN STANDARDS COLOCATION
STANDARDS A STATIC STANDARDS.
AND USUALLY WORKS WITH THE
PROVIDERS ON THEM TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY ARE GONNA BE FEASIBLE
TO DEPLOY. OKAY NOT I JUST
FINISHED UP A SOLID- OBVIOUSLY
THAT HAS HAPPENED BEFORE THOUGH
CORRECT. AND IF SO WHAT WAS THE
OUTCOME. I ASSUME MISTER CHAIR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER I'M I'M NOT I
ACTUALLY DON'T HAVE PERSONAL
KNOWLEDGE THAT THAT HAS EVER
HAPPENED BEFORE BECAUSE- AGAIN
WE TRY TO WORK IT OUT WITH THE
CITY- BUT IN ALL FAIRNESS THE
FCC IN ITS INFRASTRUCTURE
ORDERED THAT THIS BILL. WOULD
SAY WE NEED TO COME INTO
COMPLIANCE WITH IN CALIFORNIA
DOES SAY THAT THE THAT THE
STANDARDS NEED TO BE FEASIBLE
SO THAT IT DOESN'T AFFECT A
DENIAL OF SERVICE BUT I'M NOT
AWARE OF ANY CASE ON THAT. SURE
THANK YOU THANK YOU MR IS ANY
OTHER- MEMBERS HAVE COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS. YEAH WELL HOLE ON
THAT WERE AT WORK AT THE PLACE
WHERE PUBLIC COMMENT HAS ENDED
MEMBERS HAVE THE PREROGATIVE TO
ASK QUESTIONS HAVE ANSWERS TO
THOSE QUESTIONS OR MAKE
COMMENTS BUT THE PART OF THE
PORTION OF PUBLIC COMMENT HAS
ENDED. SOME ONCE AGAIN MEMBERS
DO YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS- FOR ANY OF THE
WITNESSES. MR HOLDER YEAH I
DON'T HAVE A QUESTION PER SE I
JUST KNOW THAT THESE ARE ALWAYS.
FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND
COMMUNITIES TOUGH. ISSUES TO
KIND OF RECONCILE BECAUSE ON
THE ONE HAND YOU'RE CREATING
GREATER ACCESS- AND- EXPANDING
BROADBAND WHICH AFTER LAST YEAR
OBVIOUSLY WE'RE UNDERSTANDING
HOW IMPORTANT IT IS FOR SOME
COMMUNITIES ARE GETTING. VERY
GOOD- BROADBAND TO HAVE GREATER
ACCESS TO THE INTERNET. ON THE
OTHER HAND YOU HAVE COMMUNITIES
THAT ARE ALSO AND I'M LOOKING
AT LOCAL CONTROL AND WANTED TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE NOT-
TURNING AWAY ANY OPPORTUNITY TO
MAKE SURE THERE'S A- A
REASONABLE OPPORTUNITY
INFLUENCE. HOW THESE- PROVIDERS
INTERACT WITH THE COMMUNITY IN
THE POLLS ARE TO GO UP SO I
THINK THAT THE SENATOR HAS
BASICALLY CODIFIED AS- BEEN
SAID. FEDERAL LAW THAT NOW IS-
COVERING THIS ISSUE FOR
CALIFORNIA I THINK IT'S- A FAIR
APPROACH THE ADDITIONAL.
AMENDMENTS SEEM TO MAKE- MAKES
SENSE BECAUSE THERE CAN GET TO
A PLACE WHERE- AGAIN I DON'T
THINK IT HAPPENS TOO OFTEN BUT
IF THERE'S AN IMPASSE HOW DO
YOU RESOLVE THAT AND IN A WAY
THAT ALLOWS THE SERVICE TO GO
FORWARD BECAUSE IT'S DESIGNED
TO BENEFIT THE GOOD. OF A
LARGER NUMBER OF FOLKS AND SO I
THINK THAT THIS IS A REASONABLE
APPROACH- THAT I THINK THAT
THIS IS WORTH SUPPORTING I
APPRECIATE OBVIOUSLY THE- THE
NARROW FOCUS THAT THIS
COMMITTEE HAS A NO LOCAL
GOVERNMENT HAD AN OPPORTUNITY
TO SORT OF RUSSELL SOME OF
THESE LARGER ISSUES THAT EVEN
COME UP TODAY. BUT WITHIN THE
PURVIEW OF THIS COMMITTEE AND
WITH THE RECOMMENDATION OF THE
CHAIR I'M PREPARED TO MOVE A-
YEAH. THANK YOU MR HOLDER AND
THE AUTHOR AND I DID TALK AND
THERE'S AN AWARENESS HE'S GOING
TO CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS
BILL- IF YOU DON'T MIND ME
SAYING IT ON ON HIS BEHALF AND
IN CONTINUE ALSO WORKING ON ON
A ON A QUESTION OF EXISTING.
CONTRACTS NOW IN ALL FAIRNESS
THAT CAN BE TAKEN UP DOWN THE
LINE BECAUSE OF THE AMBIGUITY
AS TO WHAT SOME OF THAT UP TO.
YOU CAN HEAR ME THERE IN TERMS
OF WHAT SOME OF THAT OPPOSITION
MEMBERS HAVING SAID THAT- IN
THE SPIRIT OF NATURE OF WHAT
YOU WERE SAYING AS WELL- NOW
FOR IN FEDERAL BACK TO
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND ASK IF
THERE'S ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS- AND IT WAS AN
EXCELLENT CLOSE EARLY BUT- AND
IF THERE'S ANY- ANY- CLOSING.
CLOSING COMMENTS THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN I WANT TO THANK
OUR WITNESSES AS WELL- ON
BEHALF OF SENATOR DODD I KNOW
THAT HE IS MAKING GOOD FAITH
NEGOTIATIONS AT THIS TIME WITH
ALL STAKEHOLDERS- AND WITH THAT
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I
BILL ON BEHALF OF. SO WE HAVE
WITNESS HOLDER. AS YOU MISTER
PRIME MINISTER- THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ITEM NUMBER TWO SB FIVE FIVE
SIX THE MOTION'S DAY PASSED
APPROPRIATIONS SANTIAGO HI
SANTIAGO AYE PATTERSON.
BOERNER HORVATH BOERNER HORVATH
HI I'M BRIAN. BRENT HI BENNETT
DAVIES. DAVIES NO EDUARDO
GARCIA THEN HOLDEN I LOW WORKS
OVER. QUICK SILVA AYE RODRIGUEZ
ELDERS BUILDERS I. WEBER WEBER
HI. IS SEVEN KNOWS ONE THAT
BILLS ON CALL. THANK YOU- M.
AND A CENTRE GONZALEZ WOULD WE
PROCEED WITH ITEM THREE THAT
WOULD BE S. B. FOR ON OUR SIDE
IF YOU'RE COMFORTABLE WITH THAT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR GOOD
AFTERNOON THAT SHARED MEMBERS
AGAIN I'M HERE TO PRESENT NOW
MY BILL SB FOUR WHICH IS A
CRITICAL MEASURING CLOSING THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE BOTH DURING AND
AFTER THE CODE NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. AS WE KNOW ACROSS THE
STATE IN IN ALL OF OUR
DISTRICTS. WOULD YOU LIVE IN
RURAL OR URBAN CALIFORNIA WE
HAVE SEEN EXAMPLES OF HOW THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE IS PREVENTING
CALIFORNIANS FROM ENGAGING IN
CRITICAL DIGITAL ACTIVITIES.
WHETHER IT BE STUDENTS HAVING
TO GO TO A TACO BELL IN SALINAS
IN THE PARKING LOT TO GET A
WIFI CONNECTION OR OLDER
CALIFORNIANS WHO DO NOT HAVE
FAST ENOUGH INTERNET TO RECEIVE
TELEHEALTH SERVICES. OR TO
CONNECT THEIR FAMILIES THIS
BILL WILL REDEFINE ELIGIBILITY
REQUIREMENTS FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ADVANCED SERVICES FUND TO
ENABLE INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS
TO BE BUILT. IN UNSERVED AND
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES THIS
CHANGING CRITERIA WILL HELP
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND INTERNET
SERVICE PROVIDERS OF ALL SIZES.
TO APPLY FOR GRANTS AT AT THE
SAME TIME INVEST IN TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY INTERNET
INFRASTRUCTURE. SB FOUR WILL
ALSO STABILIZE THE FUNDING
SOURCE FOR THE ADVANCED
SERVICES FUND BY EXTENDING THE
SUNSET ON THE PROGRAM AND
SURCHARGE FOR AN ADDITIONAL TEN
YEARS WHILE CAPPING THE FORMER
PERCENTAGE BASE FEE. TO ONE
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS A
YEAR. THE BILL WILL PROVIDE
CRITIC CRITICAL FUNDING GRANTS
TO UNSERVED AND UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES AS MENTIONED TO
ALSO BUILD HIGH SPEED FIBRE
BROADBAND NETWORKS AT MINIMUM
SPEEDS OF ONE HUNDRED MEGABYTES
PER SECOND DOWNLOAD. AND TWENTY
MEGABYTES PER SECOND UPLOAD
WHICH IS CURRENTLY BEING A
RECONCILE THE NEGOTIATED
BIPARTISAN LEE AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL. SB FOUR HAS A GROWING A
DIVERSE COALITION OF OVER A
HUNDRED SUPPORTERS AND
ORGANIZATIONS AND I ALSO WANT
TO THANK THE CHAIR SANTIAGO FOR
WORKING WITH US AS WELL AS-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. AYE GARCIA
WHO'S BEEN IN THIS FIGHT AS
WELL. TESTIFYING AND IN SUPPORT
TODAY HAVE ERNESTO FUND GONE
SENIOR REGISTER LEGISLATIVE
COUNSEL FOR THE ELECTRONIC
FRONTIER FOUNDATION ND
KIMBERLY ROSENBERGER AT
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA. STATE
COUNCIL SEIU THANK YOU. WE MAKE
A BEGIN I'M GONNA GIVE HER A-
THAT WE'RE DOING FOR MINUTES ON
EACH SIDE SO NOT. GENTLY NO
JEWETT ABOUT TWO MINUTES- IT
MAY PROCEED MISTER FALCON.
MISTER MODERATOR. THANK YOU AYE
AYE DIARRHEA AYE BUDGET
SANTIAGO BY SIR PATTERSON
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE- MY
NAME THERE AT THE FARGO NINE
THE SENIOR LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL
FOR THE ELECTRONIC FRONTIER
FOUNDATION BOB MY RESEARCH FOR
THE ORGANIZATION AND FOCUSED ON
HOW WE BUILD OUR TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY READY ACCESS TO ALL
PEOPLE AND MORE IMPORTANTLY HOW
WE AVOID THE MISTAKES OF THE
PAST OF GIVEN THE DIGITAL
DIVIDE WE HAVE TODAY. ON AS
I'VE MENTIONED BEFORE TO THIS
COMMITTEE FIBER OPTIC THE
FOUNDATION OF ALL FUTURE READY
PROPERTY ACCESS WHETHER IT'S
WIRELESS OR WIRED WITHOUT
EXCEPTION SB FOUR MAKE
SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS IN PUSHING
FIBER INFRASTRUCTURE BUT BRING
UP OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
PURSUE COMMUNITY EFFORTS TO
DELIVER FIBER AT FAULT
INCREASING FUNDING TO ITS GRANT
PROGRAM FOR LOCAL PRIVATE AND
LOCAL PUBLIC PROVIDERS. THE
GRANT PROGRAM REFLECTS OUR
GOVERNANCE AND EXECUTIVE ORDER
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY ALLOWS YOU
CUTIE QUICKLY CHECK THE PROGRAM
TO LEVERAGE FEDERAL DOLLARS
SHOULD CONGRESS COME THROUGH
WITH PRESIDENT BY THEN ROBIN
PLAN TO BUILD FUTURE. PROGRAM
RESEARCH OF ALL AMERICANS. IT
THIS BILL IS ALONG GOVERNOR OF.
TO A LONGER FINE. TO ENABLE BY
FINANCE. ROBIN EFFORTS. HELLO
WILL CREATED THE MOST. APPROACH
TO DELIVERING 20% THREE ACTORS
UNIVERSALLY OCTAVE BAND ANY
OTHER NATION ANY OTHER STATE IN
THE COUNTRY. HELP WE HAVE THE
CHANCE TO LEAD THE NATION. BOB
I NEED ONLY MORE PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE PROVIDERS THE BUILDER
AND SOLVE THEIR OWN PROBLEMS ON
THE GROUND. AND I- INCLUSION I
WANT TO THANK CENTER AT LINCOLN
DOLLARS FOR LEADERSHIP IN THE
STATE OF ALL THE GOVERNOR AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ON YOUR CURRY-
THEIR VISION FOR THE
COMMUNICATIONS INFRASTRUCTURE
FOR CALIFORNIA REFLECTS MUCH OF
WHAT PRESIDENT BY THEM THAT. IF
THEY DO FOR THE COUNTRY. THIS
IS HOW WE WILL AND DIGITAL FIVE
OR CHILDREN GRANDCHILDREN. AND
I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISS CAN- ROSSUM
PLEASE. IF YOU'RE ON. YES THANK
YOU- WE ARE PLEASED TO
COSPONSOR THIS BILL WE THINK IT
IS IMPORTANT IN ADDRESSING THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE- IT HAS ALWAYS
BEEN AN ISSUE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES PUTTING LOWER
INCOME STUDENTS AND
DISADVANTAGED BUT WITH THE
PANDEMIC THAT REALLY SHINED A
LIGHT ON HOW IMPACTFUL THIS
DIVIDE IS ON OUR MOST
VULNERABLE STUDENT POPULATIONS
ARE HOLDING COMMUNITIES CAME
TOGETHER TO ADAPT TO A NEW
LEARNING ENVIRONMENT PROVIDING
CAPLET AND PARTNERING WITH
PUBLIC TELEVISION. TO ATTEMPT
TO REACH AS MANY THINGS AS
POSSIBLE DESPITE HER
SIGNIFICANT EFFORTS A LACK OF
BIBLE IN AFFORDABLE INTERNET
ACCESS REALLY HAMSTRUNG ATTEMPT
TO PROVIDE QUALITY EDUCATION AT
THE REPRESENT CLASSIFIED
WORKERS IN THE MOST POPULOUS
DISTRICT WE ARE SEEING A
SIGNIFICANT LEARNING GAP AMONG
OUR LOW INCOME STATE AND
THERE'S A CLEAR CORRELATION
BETWEEN ACCESS AND DIGITAL
RESOURCES AND- IMPACT. WOULD
HAVE BEEN BURNING WE CAN SAY
WITH CERTAINTY THAT RELIABLE
INTERNET ACCESS IS NOT A
PROBLEM FOR RURAL COMMUNITIES
BUT EVEN UNRELIABLE NETWORK FOR
THE CONSISTENT PROBLEM IN THE
DISTANCE LEARNING SYSTEMS
IMPORTANT CHANGES ON HOW WE
DEFINE UNDERSERVED AREAS AS
WELL AS PROVIDING A MORE
SUSTAINABLE FUNDING MECHANISM
EXPANSION PLANS. FOR THE
REASONS MENTIONED ABOVE WERE IN.
STRONG AND- DR- THANK YOU. MR
MODERATOR WE HAVE ONE A PRIMARY
WE IN OFFICE. TO BY PHONE.
MISTER DUSTIN- WEATHERBY WITH
CALIFORNIA'S ASSOCIATION. ARE
YOU THERE. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHECKING HERE ME YES NOT FOR
MONEY OF FOUR MINUTES ON EACH
SIDE. OUR OFFICE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR MEMBERS THIS DEFICIT
WHETHER B. AND I'M A POLICY
ADVOCATE AT THE CALIFORNIA
TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION THANK YOU
FOR PROVIDING ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO YOU
TODAY. TELL TAX RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSES SB FOUR BECAUSE THE
BILL WOULD INCREASE TAXES ON
PHONES UP TO TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY TO
FUND THE EXPANSION OF BROADBAND
PROJECTS THE DEAF AND DISABLED
HEALTH HOME PROGRAM. MAKE NO
MISTAKE SB FOUR IS A
SIGNIFICANT TAX. CALIFORNIANS
ALREADY PAY SIGNIFICANT TAXES
ON THE PHONE SERVICE AND SB
FOUR MAKES PHONE SERVICE EVEN
MORE EXPENSIVE BY INCREASING
TAX. TAXES ON A TAXPAYERS PHONE
BILLS. BY CHOOSING TO USE THE
PHONE BILLS ACTORS AND TAX
COLLECTION SERVICE. FOR NEW
GOVERNMENT PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES. CALIFORNIA'S CHOOSING
TO MAKE THE COST OF A PHONE
LESS AFFORDABLE. ON AVERAGE A
TYPICAL WIRELESS CUSTOMER IN
THE STATE HE MORE THAN 23% OF
THE TOTAL PHONE BILL AND FEES
TAXES AND SURCHARGES TO THE
FEDERAL STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS IN TWENTY TWENTY.
WE ALSO QUESTION WHETHER
ADDITIONAL REVENUE IS THAT
NECESSARY AT THIS TIME. NOW THE
CALIFORNIA WILL RECEIVE FUNDS
FROM THE AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN
ACT WHICH INCLUDES SPONSORED
EARMARKED FOR BROADBAND
INFRASTRUCTURE. INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECTS. CALIFORNIA ISSUE
LIGHTS FEDERAL FUNDING IN THE
PROJECTED SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS
IN ADDITIONAL STATE FUNDING
FROM THE BUDGET FOR THESE
PROJECTS BEFORE ASKING
TAXPAYERS FOR MORE. SO IN
ADDITION TO THAT. THE TICKET
FUNDING. MADE BY THE
LEGISLATURE THE STATE IS
PROJECTED TO HAVE A RECORD
TWENTY FIVE POINT TWO BILLION
RESERVE AND A SEVENTY FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS SURPLUS FROM
THE LATEST BUDGET. WHICH IS WHY
THE GOVERNOR AND ADMINISTRATION
OFFICIALS HAVE STATED THE
INITIAL PRACTICE ARE
UNNECESSARY IN THE CURRENT
APARTMENT. GIVEN THESE REASONS
CALTECH'S MUST RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE SB FOUR THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NOW WE GO ANY
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT AND WITNESS-
BOB THE IN THE CHAMBERS AND I
WAS INFORMED WE HAVE TWO PEOPLE
IN THE CHAMBER- AND WE WOULD DO
NAME ORGANIZATION POSITIONALLY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS BERNIE OROZCO
CALIFORNIA CABLE AND
TELECOMMUNICATIONS ASSOCIATION
WE ARE IN SUPPORT IF AMENDED
THANK YOU THANK YOU. I BELIEVE
YOU HAVE ONE MORE WITNESS. THEN
I MAY HAVE BEEN MISINFORMED WE
HAVE ONE ANY ADDITIONAL US
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION WITNESSES
IN THE REMOTE. A TESTIMONY ROOM.
ANY ADDITIONAL- SUPPORTER
OPPOSITION WITNESSES ON THE
PHONE- MISTER MODERATOR. AND
AGAIN WE WOULD REMIND YOU STATE
YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION
ADDITIONALLY. STATE YOUR
POSITION TO ASK BEFORE ME PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO USING YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. WELL THE
FIRST TO LINE ONE TWENTY TWO.
THAT AFTERNOON SHARON MEMBERS
THIS IS DONNA HOFFMAN PHONING
WITH COUNSEL FOR STRONG AMERICA
AND READY NATION APART. ONE
THAT NINETY SEVEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON WENT AWAY WITH
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY IN SUPPORT. NINE TWO
ONE ONE TWO ELEVEN. THIS IS
CINDY TO BE HILLARY WITH
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANK. ONE TEN. GOOD AFTERNOON.
MEMBERS THIS IS DANA COMPLEMENT
THE LEADER CALIFORNIA CITIES IN
SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL FOR. ONE
THIRTEEN. THE CARD LAYING ON
TOP OF THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
AND BUTTE AND NEVADA COUNTIES
TO SUPPORT THIS AFTERNOON THANK
YOU. TWO THIRTEEN. SHARE ABOUT
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
SCHOOL BUSINESS OFFICIALS IN
SUPPORT. TO FOURTEEN. ARE NOT
AVAILABLE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA AT COALITION IN
SUPPORT. I'LL JUST SAY ALONG.
TO EIGHTEEN. YEAH JOHNSON ABOUT
OF THE COUNTY SAN DIEGO AND
SCRIPT HELP AND SUPPORT OF THE
PEOPLE THANK YOU. MY NAME IS.
TO ONE. HAVE YOU LEVELS CREWS
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
FORD ACTION FUND IN SUPPORT.
TWO ONE TWENTY FOUR. BOB ON
BEHALF OF THE WORLD COCKETT
CALIFORNIA MCCARTY. GENERAL-
CURRENT K. SITUATION. IT WOULD
ALIGN EIGHTY SEVEN. CAROLINA
FOOD ON BEHALF OF A BILL YOU
CAN'T ACTION IN SUPPORT. ONE
SEVENTY ONE. ONE SEVEN ONE YOU
MAY GO AHEAD. WELL MOVED L. ONE
EIGHTY THREE. JONATHAN HOWARD
WITH THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION ON BEHALF THE
STATE SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TONY THURMOND-
SPONSORED THE BILL STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. ONE TWENTY
THREE. YES- I AM- ONLY IN
SUPPORT OF THAT ASPECT OF IT
WHICH- WOULD PROMOTE WHY YOUR
TECHNOLOGY THAT STUDIES THAT
SHOW THAT ORGANIZATION
POSITIONALLY MISTER MODERATED
TO THE NEXT PERSON. ONE NINETY
ONE. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
KENNETH JACKSON CALLING ON
BEHALF OF ITS ABILITY RIGHT
CALIFORNIA HERE IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL THANK YOU. ONE NINETY
TWO. ONE NINE TWO WERE YOU ON
MUTE. WE'LL GO. TO ONE FIFTY
ONE. FIND. ONE FIFTY ONE ONE
FIVE ONE. MOVED OUT ONE FORTY
NINE. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ROGER
DICKINSON OF THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMISSION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. TWO
NINETEEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
TERROR MEMBERS OF RON RAPP
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
WE ARE PROUD CO SPONSORS OF SB
FOUR AND RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU. ONE
FIFTEEN. ALL THIS IS OLGA
SHILOH OF LOS ANGELES UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND SUPPORT.
NINETY FIVE. GOOD AFTERNOON
ANGELINA TEACHERS ON BEHALF OF
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE
OF EDUCATION AND SUPPORT. TWO
TWENTY TWO. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR MEMBERS CALL HOLLY
CALLING ON BEHALF THE CITIES OF
LONG BEACH AND WEBER SACRAMENTO
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AS BEFORE.
TWO FIFTEEN. NINE MEMBERS WILL
BE A THREE SHOT ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF BEVERLY HILLS THAT
WERE AMENDED. ONE THIRTY FIVE.
HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
NOT THE DHALIWAL WITH
TECHNICALLY COLLABORATIVE IN
STRONG SUPPORT AS BEFORE
. FORTY
NINE FOUR ZERO. ONE TO TWO
TWENTY FIVE. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR MEMBERS JOSH WITH THE PAY
ON BEHALF OF UTILITY REFORM
NETWORK IN SUPPORT IT AMEND IT.
ONE SEVENTY ONE. HELLO I
CHAIRED MEMBERS THIS IS
CHANTELLE CAPPA MCLAUGHLIN WITH
ACCESS HUMBOLDT IN EUREKA IN
SUPPORT OF SB FOUR. THE TONIGHT.
TWO TWENTY SEVEN READ A COUPLE-
RECEIVE RYAN ARE THE HAVE THE
WORLD KIND REPRESENTS THE
CALIFORNIA AND THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
IN STRONG SUPPORT. NEXT WE HAVE
TO TWENTY SIX THE BOOK. JUST A
MOMENT PLEASE WE DO HAVE TWO
MORE PENDING. TWO TWENTY EIGHT
TWO TWO EIGHT. BUT THE NAMES OF
THE CRITICAL THING WITH THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY BUSINESS
FEDERATION WE HAVE A SUPPORT
WITH AMENDMENT POSITION ON THIS
BILL THANK YOU. TWO TWENTY SIX.
YES HI MY NAME IS JULIE LEVINE
CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES OKAY I
ACTUALLY WAS SPEAKING ON SENATE
BILL FIVE FIFTY SIX OPPOSED.
THANK YOU. NO FOR THE LINES
INTO IT THIS TIME. THANK YOU WE
HAVE A COUPLE OF ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS OF THE CHAMBER WHO WILL
STATE YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION
AND POSITION ONLY. AND WE'LL GO
TO QUESTIONS WERE- MEMBERS. MY
NAME IS PAUL THE GAVIN MIGHT
ORGANIZATION IS QUOTE. MILLIONS
OF CALIFORNIANS WITH TONIGHT US
THAT'S HEARING LOSS AND RINGING
IN THE EARS BECAUSE MY WIRELESS
INFRASTRUCTURE NAMER GRADATION
AND WITH MY ORGANIZATION I'M
NOT ORGANIZATION RIVAS US
DEPARTMENT TREASURY WERE
TURNING OUT THE MICROPHONE AT
THIS POINT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND UNLESS WE HAVE SOMEBODY
ELSE'S PRESENTING. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR NAME ORGANIZATION
A POSITION ONLY. GOOD AFTERNOON
SHARE SANTIAGO MEMBERS IS THIS
MICROPHONE ON YES SIR GOOD.
MARK GRAHAM ON BEHALF OF KEEP
CELL ANTENNAS AWAY I HAVE SOME
CRITICISM FOR THE COMMITTEE
WHICH BY LAW YOU MAY NOT
PROHIBIT THAT MANY
ORGANIZATIONS TRANSITION THE
ONLY MEETING AT HAND
ORGANIZATION ADDITIONAL TURNING
OFF THE MICROPHONE AND WE'RE
NOW MOVING THE COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
MANY COMMITTEE MEMBER WOULD
HAVE THE HAS A QUESTION OR
COMMENT- BY THE WAY THE FIRST
MINISTER HOLDEN. SECOND
MINISTER BRIAN. NOT HEARING ANY
MEMBERS- COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
JUST WANNA MAKE SURE I DON'T
MISS ANYBODY- MISS GONZALEZ
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
HARD WORK AND I. WELCOME YOU
INVITE YOU TO YOUR CLOTHES. KEY
MEMBERS- I JUST ALSO WANT TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE CONSULTANTS
WHO DID A FANTASTIC JOB- AT THE
ANALYSIS THANK YOU VERY MUCH IS
DEPICTED. EXACTLY THE WHOLE
PICTURE OF BROADBAND THIS IS
JUST ONE SMALL PIECE OF
BROADBAND AS IT PERTAINS
CALIFORNIA BAND SERVICES FUND
BUT WE'VE GOT SIX BILLION
DOLLARS THAT WE NEED TO SPEND.
RIGHT AWAY- FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND SO WE LOOK
FORWARD TO MOVING THIS FORWARD
IN EVERY PART OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WHETHER YOU LIVE IN
SOUTH LA LIKE IRAQ PART OF
WHERE I REPRESENT RULE
CALIFORNIA. ANYWHERE BETWEEN
YOU WILL BE HOPEFULLY CONNECTED
THROUGH THESE BILLS THIS BILL
AND EIGHTY FOURTEEN WHICH IS-
MOVING ALONG UP THROUGH US
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CECILIA
AGUIAR-CURRY SO WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NAY VOTES.
THANKYOU THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED APPROPRIATIONS MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
HI ADAM NUMBER THREE. SB FOUR
MOTIONS DAY PASSED
APPROPRIATIONS SANTIAGO NINE
SANTIAGO AYE PATTERSON.
BOERNER HORVATH BRIAN BROWN
EYED BENNETT. DAVIES. NOW
BENNY'S DAVIES NO. EDUARDO
GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA I HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I LOW QUICKSILVER.
RODRIGUEZ VALLADARES BUILDERS
NOW WEBER. WEBER HI. IS FIVE
KNOWS TO THAT TELEPHONE CALL.
THANK YOU MISS- CENTER GONZALEZ
NOW WE WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO
THE LEFT OF FINAL BILL YOU'RE
PRESENTED TODAY WHICH IS ITEM
FOR S. B. THREESEVENTY EIGHT
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
LIVE PERSON WITH A SECOND
HOLDING A QUICK ENOUGH TO SEE
WHO BUT- AND I PROMISE I WILL
STOP TALKING ABOUT BROADBAND
AFTER HIS BILL- BUT THIS BILL
IS AB I'M PRESENTING SP THREE
SEVENTY EIGHT AN IMPORTANT
MEASURE A KEY COMPONENT TO
CLOSING THE DIGITAL DIVIDE AS
WELL. IT WILL PROMOTE THE
DEVELOPMENT OF BROADBAND
INFRASTRUCTURE AND INTERNET
CONNECTIVITY- TO LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS BY REQUIRING THEM
TO ALLOW FIBER CABLES TO BE
INSTALLED USING COST EFFECTIVE
TECHNIQUES INCLUDING OPEN
TRENCHING BORING THE MICRO
TRENCHING STATUS SB THIRTY
EIGHT WILL ADDRESS THIS LACK OF
CONTINUITY- WHERE EVERY
COMMUNITY IS A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT RIGHT NOW BY CREATING
A STATEWIDE STANDARD FOR MICRO
TRENCHING AS A DEPLOYMENT
OPTION FOR BROADBAND.
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT TODAY I
HAVE A SHELF ONCE AND
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS MANAGER WITH
CROWN CASTLE AND ERICA HOFFMAN
LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL. BOARDS
ASSOCIATION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. EMMA SWANSON YOU MAY
PROCEED FOLLOWED BY AN MIS
HUFFMAN. AND JUST REMIND IN
JUNE THANK YOU FOR MINUTES
BETWEEN THE TWO THANKS. RIGHT
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE HI MY NAME IS
ROCHELLE SWANSON GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS MANAGER FOR CROWN
CASTLE. MY VERY PROUD TO
SPONSOR SB THREE SEVENTY EIGHT
YOU CAN ALLOW BROADBAND
PROJECTS IN THE STATE G. DON'T
QUIT GROWTH WITHIN TIME
REDUCING CONSTRUCTION IMPACTING
COMMUNITIES. THE BILL INSURANCE
TO THE INDUSTRY BEST PRACTICE
OF MICRO TRENCHING THE LED BY
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS TO INSTALL
HIGH SPEED INTERNET FIBER
CABLES UNDERGROUND. MICHAEL
CHANGING TECHNOLOGY CUT A TWO
INCH WIDE INTO BUT IF YOU
TRANSFER THE FIBER UNDERGROUND
BY SIMULTANEOUSLY BACK FILLING
AND SEALING. THE ENTIRE PROCESS
TAKES HOURS RATHER THAN DAYS IN
CARS CAN DRIVE ON THE ROAD THE
SAME DAY. MY CONTENTION IS
TYPICALLY 50% CHEAPER 80%
QUICKER THAN TRADITIONAL OPEN
TRENT STREET EXCAVATIONS WHICH
CREATE LANE CLOSURES AND
NEGATIVELY IMPACT
NEIGHBORHOODS. THIS TECHNOLOGY
IS BEING USED IN CITIES AROUND
THE COUNTRY AND HAS BEEN
SUCCESSFULLY DEPLOYED IN LOS
ANGELES FOR OVER FORTY MILES OF
FIBER HAVE BEEN INSTALLED ON
MAKES IT MUCH. THE BILL HAS
NECESSARY BECAUSE MANY LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS ARE HESITANT TO
UTILIZE THIS NEWER TECHNOLOGY A
CITY STAFFER USED TO THE OLDER
MORE DESTRUCTIVE METHODS
METHODS OF OPEN TRENCHING.
MICRO TRENCHING COMPLIES WITH
ALL UTILITY SAFETY RULES AND
GOES FURTHER BY USING GROUND
PENETRATING RADAR PRIOR TO
INSTALLATION. QUICKER
INSTALLATION OF FIBER MEANS
COMMUNITIES AROUND THE STATE
CAN GET CONNECTED TO HIGH SPEED
INTERNET IN DAYS INSTEAD OF
MONTHS. IT'LL COMPLEMENT THE
STATE'S EFFORTS TO PROVIDE MORE
FUNDING FOR BROADBAND BY
ENSURING THAT PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE DOLLARS ON MAXIMIZE.
AND BENEFIT RESIDENTS QUICKLY
AS POSSIBLE. WE APPRECIATE THE
COLLABORATION WITH LOCAL
pUTILITY GREAT TO WORK WITH US
ON AMENDMENTS. WE ARE NOW AND
TORN UNETHICAL ON THE BILL. WE
CAN ENSURE SANTIAGO AND SENATOR
GONZALEZ FOR ALL YOUR WORK ON
ADVANCING BLOOD IN THE STATE.
AND RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
AYE THAT TODAY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISS HOFFMAN. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY
NAME IS ERICA HOFFMAN AND THE
LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION. COPA'S COMMITTED
TO BROADBAND EXPANSION
EXPANSION IN CALIFORNIA TO
CLOSE THE DIGITAL DIVIDE AND
IMPROVE LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES
FOR ALL OF OUR STUDENTS THIS
LAST YEAR HAS SHOWN. THAT NOW
MORE THAN EVER THE STATE NEEDS
TO DO ALL IT CAN TO CONNECT OUR
SCHOOLS AND STUDENTS DIE SPEED
INTERNET. WE SUPPORT SB THREE
SEVENTY EIGHT BECAUSE IT ALLOWS
FOR MICRO TENT TRENCHING FOR
THE QUICK INSTALLATION OF FIBER
FOR HIGH SPEED. INTERNET
PROJECTS. THIS BILL WILL HAVE
AN IMMEDIATE MEANINGFUL IMPACT
BY ALLOWING FLAG OR TO BE
INSTALLED. IN HOURS INSTEAD OF
WEEKS. MICROTONES YOU CAN
EXPEDITE DEVELOPMENT IN A FAR
LESS INVASIVE MANNER THAN
TRADITIONAL TRENCHING. OTHER
STATE AND SCHOOLS NAVIGATE
EDUCATION IN THE TIME OF
COVERED NINETEEN THE NEED FOR
MORE BROADBAND. ACCESS HAS
BECOME ABUNDANTLY CLEAR
BROADBAND NETWORKS AND SERVICES
ARE CRITICAL FOR EDUCATION BUT
ALSO FOR HEALTHCARE
TELEMEDICINE PUBLIC SAFETY AND
EMERGENCY RESPONSE. RURAL
COMMUNITIES AND LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS WITHOUT ACCESS TO
HIGH QUALITY BROADBAND ARE
CURRENTLY AT AN IMMEDIATE
DISADVANTAGE. AS SCHOOLS
CONTINUE WITH DISTANCE LEARNING
FOR SOME STUDENTS AND ALSO
BATES HOMEWORK AND SCHOOL
RESEARCH PROJECTS. ON THE
DIGITAL PLATFORM THOSE IN RURAL
COMMUNITIES IN LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS NEED TO BE CONNECTED
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT
STUDENTS. HAVE ACCESS TO ALL
APPROPRIATE EDUCATION PROGRAMS
WITHOUT ACCESS STUDENTS WILL
NOT PROGRESS AND SUCCEED. SB
THREE SEVENTY EIGHT AS
NECESSARY IN ORDER TO EXPEDITE
BROADBAND ACCESS TO COMMUNITIES
IN NEED. CSTA SUPPORT FUNDING
AND STREAMLINING TO HELP
ACCELERATE BROADBAND
DEPLOYMENT. THIS BILL WILL MAKE
SURE THE STATE AND FEDERAL
BROADCAST FUNDING WILL BENEFIT
LOCAL COMMUNITIES AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE FOR ALL THESE REASONS
WE STRONGLY URGE YOUR AYE VOTE.
ON THIS MEASURE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. AS YOU NEVER GOING TO WIN
ABA WILL BE GIVEN FOUR MINUTES-
SPLIT BY THE TO- WE HAVE FIRST-
MAYOR BILL TELOPEA BUILDER THE
PENA. AND SECOND WE HAVE-
JOANNA FINLEY. MADAM- I'M SORRY.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE MEMBER THIS
IS CLAUDIA BUILDUP PENA MAYOR
OF THE CITY OF THOUSAND OAKS
AND WE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE SB
THREE SEVENTY EIGHT TO BE CLEAR
THOUSAND OAKS DOES ACTUALLY
SUPPORT BROADBAND DEPLOYMENT
AND ACCESS TO THE INTERNET HAS
NEVER BEEN MORE IMPORTANT JERRY
COLBERT NINETEEN AND THAT'S
WHAT WE ALREADY A LOT OF
BROADBAND PROVIDERS TO MICRO
TRENDS FOR FIBER INSTALLATION
IN OUR LOCAL RIGHT THAT WAY BUT
IT IS DONE AT OUR DISCRETION.
WHILE SB THREE SEVENTY EIGHT
WOULD REQUIREA LOCAL AGENCY TO
ALLOW MICRO TRENCHING EIGHT
UNFORTUNATELY TAKES AWAY OUR
CONTROL AND AUTHORITY OVER OUR
OWN RIGHT THIS WAY CITY SHOULD
HAVE THE POLICE POWER TO
REGULATE THE TIME PLACE AND
MANNER. FOR HANDLING PERMIT.
NOW SB THREE SEVENTY PROVIDE
FOR EXPEDITED REVIEW AND
PROCESSING APPLICANTS M. IT
AUTHORIZED THE CITY TO SET FEES
FOR FASTER PERMITTING. BUT IF
THIS REGARD STAFF CAPACITY TO
ACTUALLY EXPEDITE THE PERMIT.
AT CITIES ACROSS THE STATE USE
SB ONE FUNDS TO REPAVE AND
REPAIR WORN STREETS AND ROADS
SB THREE SEVENTY EIGHT PROVIDE
NO ASSURANCE THAT MICROSTRATEGY
PROJECT WILL NOT DAMAGE YOU
WILL BE PAVED STREET. HERE IN
THOUSAND OAKS WHEN TELECOM
PROVIDERS INSTALLED UNDERGROUND
CABLE MANY OF OUR STREETS WERE
DAMAGED AND WE HAD TO DO FOR
REPAIR ALTHOUGH MY CREEK
TRENCHING IS SMALLER WE NEED TO
BE ABLE TO WORK WITH APPLICANTS
TO CONTROL THE DEPTH OF MICRO
TRENCHING THE OBVIOUS CONCERN
IS THAT EXCESS OF DEATH WHAT
COULD DAMAGE UNDERGROUND
UTILITIES AND COST. SECTOR PUTS
CRACK THAT OVER TIME COULD
UNDERMINE THE STRUCTURAL
INTEGRITY OF OUR PAVE STREETS
AND FOR THESE REASONS WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND I BELIEVE- MISS MISS FINNEY
IS IN THE CHAMBER IS THAT
ACCURATE CORRECT THANK YOU
MISSED ANY YOU MAKE A SALMON
HELLO I'M JOHANNA FINNEY I'M
WITH THE NEVADA COUNTY
TELECOMMUNICATIONS PUBLIC
WORKING GROUP. I URGE YOU TO
VOTE NO ON SB THREE SEVEN
EIGHT. DESPITE WHAT THE BILL'S
SPONSOR IT TELLS YOU- MICHAEL
TRENCHING IS NOT- THE BEST
PRACTICE OF THE INDUSTRY-
ACTUALLY FIBER LATERAL DRILLING
OR BORING IS THAT THE BEST
PRACTICE. AND THIS ONE SIZE
FITS ALL APPROACH IS ILL
ADVISED FAST AND CHEAP IS NOT
ALWAYS GOOD. LOCAL AUTHORITY
AND THEY'RE INTELLIGENT
PLANNING MUST BE PRESERVED TO
CHOOSE THE MANNER IN WHICH
FIBER OPTIC SHALL BE LAID.
CITIES STILL HAVE THE POLICE
POWER TO REGULATE THE TIME
PLACE AND MANNER FOR HANDLING
PERMITS GIVE ME. MAUREEN IS
OFTEN THE PREFERRED METHOD OF
MINIMIZING DAMAGE AND ONLY
REQUIRING RESTORATION AND THE
AND AT THE ENTRY AND EXIT
POINTS. SB THREE SEVEN EIGHT
DOES NOT PROVIDE FOR THE
RESTORATION OF THE TRENCH AREA
TO ITS PREVIOUS CONDITION AND
DOES NOT REQUIRE THE APPLICANTS
TO PAY FOR THIS RESTORATION.
LOUISVILLE KENTUCKY IS
DISASTROUS GOOGLE FIBER OPTICS
MICRO TRENCHING PROJECT IS A
CLEAR HARBINGER FOR CALIFORNIA.
THE CEILING DIDN'T PERFORM WELL
THE CABLES CAME OUT OF THE
TRENCHES TO LAY EXPOSED IN THE
STREETS LOCAL AUTHORITIES SPENT
PRECIOUS TIME AND ENERGY
REMOVING FIBER CABLE AND
SEALANT FROM ROADS. MILLING AND
PAVING TO RESTORE WALKWAYS AND
ROADS SYSTEMS AND REMOVING
ABOVE GROUND INFRASTRUCTURE.
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN
THOUSANDS OF MILES OF CONDUIT
ONLY A FEW INCHES UNDERGROUND
IS EXPOSED TO FLOODING FIRE
DAMAGE AND VEHICLE TRAFFIC
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA. AFTER
THE FACT THE STATE WILL SEE
THAT THESE MICRO TRENCHES HAVE
BECAUSE SPECIFIC ADVERSE IMPACT
ON THE PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY
AND THIS BILL PROVIDES NO STATE
SUPPORT OR APPROPRIATE
REIMBURSEMENT FOR THE DAMAGE
JUST GONNA GENTLY REMIND YOU
DON'T THINK I URGE YOU TO VOTE
NO ON SB THREE SEVEN EIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY VERY MUCH FOR
THAT- NOW WILL MOVE THE PUBLIC
COMMENTS. ANY ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION FROM THE
CHAMBER AND I REMIND YOU NAME
YOUR STATE SORRY YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION ONLY.
A ONCE AGAIN YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION ONLY
AND WILL BEGIN AT THE CHAMBER
IF THERE ARE ANY. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR TODD BLOOM STEIN
FOR THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
CONTRACTORS ASSOCIATION WE DO
HAVE A BRIEF HANDOUT THAT I'VE
GIVEN TO THE SERGEANTS TO
DEMONSTRATE THE ISSUE. THANK
YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU. ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN THE
CHAMBER. STATE YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION ONLY.
GOOD AFTERNOON SIR SANTIAGO
MEMBERS MARK GRAHAM ON BEHALF
OF KEEP CELL AND KIND OF THE
WAY I HAVE SOME CRITICISM FOR
THIS COMMITTEE WHICH BY LAW YOU
MUST NOT PROHIBITIVE THE NAME
OF THE ORGANIZATION TRANSITION
ONE ONLY. A BACK LIKE HE- NAME
ORGANIZATION POSITION ONLY WILL
TURN OFF THAT MAKE. ANY
ADDITIONAL- A SUPPORTER
OPPOSITION NAME ORGANIZATION OF
POSITIONALLY. YES MY NAME IS
PAULA GAVIN I APPRECIATE THE
CHAIRS RESPECT FOR MY
ORGANIZATION'S NAME WHICH IS
ABOUT TO COME PLEASE DON'T
INTERRUPT ME UNTIL I'M DONE SIR
THANK YOU THE NAME OF THE
ORGANIZATION IS QUOTE
CALIFORNIANS WHO SUPPORT DIRECT
PUBLIC ACCESS TO ANY FIBER
OPTICS INSTALLED IN THE PUBLIC
RIGHTS OF WAY WE OPPOSE THE
CHEAP MICRO CHECHEN BILL SB
THREE SEVEN EIGHT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
THAT. NOW WE'RE MOVING TO THE
REMOTE- TESTIMONY ROOM. ANY
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION WITNESSES IF THERE
ARE ANY OTHER. MISTER
MODERATOR. IF THERE ANY
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION WITNESSES ON THE
PHONE. THANK YOU PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO TO STATE YOUR
POSITION ON THIS BILL THAT'S SB
THREE SEVENTY EIGHT ONE AND
THEN ZERO WILL GO FIRST IN LINE
TO A LEVIN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIS IS CINDY HILLARY ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION IN FACT THE PORT OF
THE BILL THANK YOU. TWO TO
THIRTY TWO. GOOD AFTERNOON
JUSTIN HIGHER WITH THE SILICON
VALLEY LEADERSHIP GROUP AND WE
ARE PROUD TO SUPPORT THE BILL
THANK YOU. TWO THIRTY SIX.
POLICE STANDING. IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. ONE SEVENTY ONE.
HELLO HI THIS IS SEAN TICKET
SOME OF LAUGHLIN WITH
ACCESSIBLE IN EUREKA AND WE
OPPOSE ANY MOVE TO TAKE AWAY
LOCAL CONTROL THANK YOU. SIXTY
EIGHT- I'M SORRY HI THIS THERE
ARE CITIZENS FOR RADIATION FREE
COMMUNITY DOT ORG- THIS IS
FOUNDATION AMERICAN ASSOCIATION
FOR CELLPHONE SAFETY AND
CITIZENS WHO HAVE BEEN GIVEN TO
A SERVER OR OTHERWISE HARMED BY
WIRELESS RADIATION EMITTING-
AND TENNIS- WE STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. ONE SIXTY
SEVEN. HELLO THIS IS CONSTANCE
ANDERSON NUMBER OF WIRED IN
STRONG OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU. TWO TWO
TWENTY EIGHT. RESEARCHER AND
MEMBER CHRIS WILL FILL THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY BUSINESS
FEDERATION WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF
SB THREE SEVEN EIGHT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. TWO TWENTY THREE. I
LIVE IN MARKHAM BEYOND ON
BEHALF OF COMMON SENSE MEDIA IN
SUPPORT OF THIS AND I LIKE TO
REGISTER MY SUPPORT FOR SB FOUR
AS WELL. THANK YOU. TWO THIRTY
FOUR. TRY MELANIE FIGUEROA ON
BEHALF OF VERIZON IN STRONG
SUPPORT. NINE TO THIRTY FIVE.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS THERE A
LITTLE WITH THE BAY AREA
COUNSEL IN STRONG SUPPORT. TWO
THIRTY. GOOD AFTERNOON THAT MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MICHAEL GOT IN
HERE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE SEVENTY
EIGHT. THANK YOU. SEVENTY
SEVEN. NINE SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN ANDREA NAMASTE
REPRESENTING FIVE G. FREE
CALIFORNIA STRONGLY OPPOSED.
ONE THIRTY THREE. AND ONE
THIRTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ALMOST. TWO THIRTY SEVEN. TWO
THREE SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
WITH THAT THERE ARE NO FURTHER
LINES IN Q. THANK YOU MR
MODERATOR AND I'VE INVITED- THE
SET UP FOR. ANY COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS OR A YES. THAT'S A
QUESTION FOR THE AUTHOR ONE OF
MY CITIES HAD A CONCERN THAT
THEY WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO GO IN
AND DO QUALITY ASSURANCE
STANDARDS- ON THE BACK FELLOW-
AFTER THEY'VE DONE THE MICRO
CHANGING CAN YOU COMMENT ON
THAT BECAUSE MY UNDERSTANDING
IS CITIES STILL HAVE THAT
ABILITY TO ENSURE QUALITY
STANDARDS. YES OF COURSE THEY
WOULD HAVE THAT AUTHORITY LIKE
THEY WOULD CONTRACT WITH ANYONE
ELSE- SO YOU KNOW THE PROVIDER
WOULD WOULD WORK WITH THEM IN
THAT SENSE TO DO THE BACK FELL
BUT THIS IS THE MICRO TRENCHING
BILL IS FOCUSED MORE ON
STREAMLINING THE PROCESS OF
THIS IS ALREADY HAPPENING IN
MANY OF OUR CITIES. WE'RE JUST
TRYING TO MAKE THIS FASTER- AND
MORE STREAMLINED FOR THE
DEPLOYMENT OF BROADBAND- BUT
LOCAL I. ABILITY LAWSUIT STILL
BE IN PLACE. HOWEVER WE ARE THE
FIRST. THE SECOND THANK YOU.
MISS DAVIS ARE CONCERNE
KITCHEN HERE VOICE- AND CLARK.
BUDGETARY SORRY ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS- FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS COMMENTS. THE
REQUESTED- MA'AM CENTER YOU MAY
CLOSE WHEN IT EXITS BECKLEY
ASPIRIN I BILL THANK YOU THANK
YOU TO MOTIONS DO PASS
APPROPRIATIONS- AND SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL RULES. ITEM NUMBER
FOR SB THREE SEVEN EIGHT
EMOTIONS DAY PASSED
APPROPRIATIONS SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE PATTERSON
BOERNER HORVATH BOERNER HORVATH
I BRIAN BRAND I BENNETT DAVIES.
DAVIS I EDUARDO GARCIA EDUARDO
GARCIA I HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE
HELLO RICK SILVA HI QUICK SILVA
AYE RODRIGUEZ. RODRIGUEZ I
VALLADARES. MILITARES I WEBER.
WEBER I. IS TEN NO ZERO THAT
BILLS ON CALL. THANK YOU.
BELIEVE US SENATOR MINUTES HERE
TO. RECOGNITION FAIR PLAYING
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT
SB FIVE HUNDRED WHICH WOULD
REQUIRE ALL LIGHT DUTY
ECONOMISTS VEHICLES TO BE ZERO
EMISSION BY THE YEAR TWENTY
THIRTY- THIS MEASURE WOULD HELP
OUR STATE ACHIEVE OUR AMBITIOUS
YET. ABSOLUTELY NECESSARY CLEAN
AIR GOALS ESPECIALLY SINCE WE
KNOW THAT VEHICLES US IS- SOME
OF THE MOST TOXIC POLLUTANTS. I
ALSO WILL HELP SET THE
ECONOMIST VEHICLE FIRMLY ON
TRACK TO BE ZERO EMISSION WHICH
IS IMPORTANT GIVEN THE MILEAGE
AND PASTOR VEHICLE MILES THAT
ARE EXPECTED BE PUT ON THE ROAD
BECAUSE THE TIME IS VEHICLES.
SMART POLICIES ARE NEEDED TO
ENSURE A STEER AB DEPLOYMENT
ALONG WITH OTHER PARTS OF
TRANSPORTATION TOWARDS A ZERO
EMISSION FUTURE. AND THAT IS
THE GOAL OF THIS BILL- IS YOUR
MISSION AB TECHNOLOGY IS NOT
SOMETHING THAT'S FUTURISTIC OR
SCIENCE FICTION. IT'S THE NEAR
TERM REALITY. COMPANIES
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA HAVE
ALREADY DEMONSTRATED THAT THE
SOFTWARE AB TECHNOLOGY CAN
MATCH THE HARDWARE. ZERO
EMISSIONS TECHNOLOGY AND MOST
EXPERTS BELIEVE THE ZERO
EMISSIONS TECHNOLOGIES WELL
AHEAD OF THE AV. I IT'S A GOOD
PRESIDENTE SET BEFORE EV'S ARE
PUT THE WIDESPREAD USE AND THIS
MEASURE SUPPORTED BY A BROAD
COALITION OF ENVIRONMENTAL
PUBLIC HEALTH AND LABOR GROUPS.
THE TIME IS MICHAEL'S MAY BE
ABLE TO DRIVE THEMSELVES BUT
LET'S MAKE SURE THAT WE IN THIS
LEGISLATURE STEER THEM IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION. WITH ME ON THE
LINE TO TESTIFY TODAY I HAVE A
LIST OF IT URBAN SENIOR
TRANSPORTATION ANALYST FOR THE
UNION OF CONCERNED SCIENTISTS.
AND NADIAANDERSON SENIOR
GOVERNMENT MANAGER FOR CRUISE.
THANK YOU MY PROCEED BECAUSE
THERE'S TWO WERE DOING FOUR
MINUTES US AND- BUT GENTLY%
REMIND EVERYBODY AT THE TWO
MINUTE MARK THANK YOU. MR. ONE
GOOD MORNING OR GOOD AFTERNOON
AT YOUR SAN DIEGO COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS ELIZABETH
URBAN AND THAT SENIOR
TRANSPORTATION ANALYST AT THE
UNION OF CONCERNED SCIENTISTS.
YES YES IS THE NATION'S LEADING
SCIENCE BASED NONPROFIT PUTTING
RIGOROUS INDEPENDENT SCIENCE TO
WORK TO SOLVE OUR NATION'S. AND
PLANETS MOST PRESSING PROBLEMS.
ON BEHALF OF UPS'S FORTY FOUR
THOUSAND PLUS SUPPORTERS IN
CALIFORNIA. I AM PLEASED TO
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO THE
COMMITTEE TODAY I IN SUPPORT OF
SB FIVE HUNDRED WHICH WOULD
REQUIRE AUTOMATED VEHICLES TO
BE DEPLOYED A ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES. THERE'S AN EXPERT
CONSENSUS THAT ELECTRIFYING
EV'S IS ONE OF THE ESSENTIAL
COMPONENTS TO ENSURING THAT
THERE ARE SUSTAINABLE PART OF
OUR TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM. FOR
EXAMPLE RESEARCH FROM UC DAVIS
FOUND THAT PERSONALLY OWNED AB
IS UNLIKELY TO SIGNIFICANTLY
INCREASE VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED
WITH A LARGE PORTION OF THOSE
MILD COMING WINDOW PASSENGERS
IN THE VEHICLE. AND THE EV'S
ARE LIKELY TO SHIFT PEOPLE AWAY
FROM LOWER EMISSION MODE. IF
YES RESEARCH FOUND THE
POTENTIAL FOR AB TO INCREASE
EMISSIONS AND AIR POLLUTION
EVEN IN A SCENARIO WHERE
POLICIES ENCOURAGE COOLING IN
TRANSIT. OUR RESEARCH ALSO
FOUND THAT NEGATIVE IMPACTS
CONGESTION AND AIR POLLUTION
WERE LIKELY TO HAPPEN
DISPROPORTIONATELY IN
COMMUNITIES ALREADY
EXPERIENCING ENVIRONMENTAL
INJUSTICES. WE CAN ALSO LEARN
FROM THE RAPID DEPLOYMENT OF
RIDE HAILING. WHICH USED YET
AND CARBON HAS FOUND TO
INCREASE EMISSIONS COMPARED TO
PERSONALCARS. ACCORDING TO UCS
ANALYSIS THE AVERAGE RIDE
HAILING TRIPS IT 69% MORE
POLLUTING THAN THE TRAINS THEY
REPLACE. THESE REPORTS AND
OTHERS HIGHLIGHT THE NEED TO
DEPLOY AB IS AS AS IN ORDER TO
MITIGATE EMISSIONS IMPACT AS
PART OF A BROADER STRATEGY TO
REDUCE EMISSIONS FOR
TRANSPORTATION. THE OVERALL
DIRECTION OF CALIFORNIA POLICY
IT'S CLEAR WE'RE MOVING TOWARD
AS YOU'RE A MISSION
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEMS AND
EMERGING TECHNOLOGIES LIKE
AUTOMATED VEHICLE SHOULD BE
LEADING THE WAY. THIS BILL
CONSISTENT WITH OTHER
GOVERNMENT ACTIONS SUCH AS THE
EXECUTIVE ORDERS REQUIRING
TRANSITION TO THAT IN CARD THE
PASSENGER TRUCKS. CHARACTERS
DRAFT FRAMEWORK- WHICH LISTS
DEPLOYMENT OF YOUR MISSION AB
THAT'S PART OF ITS FIRST
GUIDING PRINCIPLE. AND TO CLEAN
MILE STANDARD- APPROVED BY CARP
THAT REQUIRES RIDE HAILING
VEHICLES TO TRANSITION TO THAT.
RIGHT CLEAN A REGULATED SEGMENT
BUT NOT ALL EIGHTIES. JUST
NOTHING ARE ALREADY DEPLOYING-
AB THANK YOU- THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TODAY AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU TO VOTE IN
FAVOR OF SB FIVE HUNDRED. THANK
YOU MISS ANDERSON PLEASE.
AFTERNOON CHECKING GADDA
RESPECTED COMMITTEE MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME TODAY
MY NAME IS NOT A ANDERSON I'M A
NUMBER OF REASONS GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS TEAMS I'M HERE TODAY TO
EXPRESS OUR STRONG SUPPORT
CRAPPIE FIVE HUNDRED. OUR
MISSION DRIVING TECHNOLOGY
COMPANY WITH A MISSION TO BRING
THE LOT ABOUT THE DANCE ACADEMY
ACROSS. THE STATE WE CONNECT
PEOPLE TO THE PLACE I THINK THE
NEXT BEST A CARE. GIVER FAMILY
ON THE PLANET THE
TRANSPORTATION AT THE END OF
THE DAY A FUNDAMENTALLY FLAWED.
AND IT'S PRETTY NEAT THE STATE
ENVIRONMENT LOCAL NEED MORE
THEIR ADMISSION BE UP ON THE
BACK. AS YOU ALL KNOW
TRANSPORTATION IS ONE OF THE
BIGGEST CONTRIBUTORS TO AIR
POLLUTION. AND OTHER HARMFUL
HEALTH AND ECONOMIC IMPACTS
RELATED TO KIND OF TAKE THAT. I
VISIBLE IN OUR COMMUNITY TODAY.
WE BELIEVE THAT THE CURRENT
IDENTIFICATION ALONG WITH THE
WIDESPREAD ELECTRIFICATION
UNNECESSARY FOR MITIGATING THE
NEGATIVE CONSEQUENCES. APPROVED
FOR AFTER DISAPPOINTED CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION REVOLUTION. A
VEHICLE HAD BEEN THERE A
MISSION SINCE DAY ONE AND
CALIFORNIA HAVE BEEN POWERED BY
A 100% FOR NOBLE ENERGY.
GENERATED RIGHT HERE IN OUR
HOME STATE TWENTY NINETY. WHERE
PAKISTAN WITH A BROAD COALITION
INCLUDING ENVIRONMENTAL AND
LABOR GROUP. AND SEVERAL OF OUR
PEERS AND EIGHTY INDUSTRY
TARGETS A PART OF THAT THAT. WE
FIRMLY BELIEVE THAT POLITICIANS
OF CALIFORNIA FEATURE BUT
ECONOMICALLY AND
ENVIRONMENTALLY AND I MAKE IT
CLEAR INVESTMENT AND THEY'RE
MISSING VEHICLES AND THE
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDED THE POWER
THE VEHICLE. CALIFORNIA CONCERT
AT THE SHINING EXAMPLE WHAT THE
CLEAN ENERGY TRANSITION SHOULD
LOOK LIKE IN THE COMING YEARS.
BUT I THINK FIVE HUNDRED
CALIFORNIANS THAT OFFENDER FOR
HOW WE BUILD FACEBOOK FEATURE
FOR TRANSPORTATION. MAKING
STRIDES TOWARD MEETING I AM
BESTEN CRIME CALL. WE BELIEVE
THAT EIGHTY PARA CRITICAL ROLE
TO PLAY IN THE INNOVATION AND
THEIR MISSION GO HAND IN HAND.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO BE HEARD TODAY AND EXTRACT
THE POINT ON THIS VERY
IMPORTANT THAT. WE RESPECTFULLY
ASK ABOUT THE PAPER SB FIVE
HUNDRED TODAY. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. NOW WILL MOVE TOWARD-
OPPOSITION- WITNESSES. AND ON
JEWISH TO ME. I DO WE ARE
MISTER I- MODERATOR PLEASE YEAH
THANK MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU.
YOU MAY PROCEED ABOUT THAT YEAH.
OKAY THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK
YOU- MISTER SHARE MY NAME IS
KURT AUGUSTINE I AND SENIOR
DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS
FOR THE ALLIANCE FOR AUTOMOTIVE
INNOVATION WHICH IS THE TRADE
ASSOCIATION OF AUTO
MANUFACTURERS AND THE
TECHNOLOGY SUPPLIERS OF BOTH
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES AND
AUTONOMOUS VEHICLE TECHNOLOGY-
WE APPRECIATE THE PREVIOUS
AMENDMENTS MADE BY THE SENATOR
TO THE BILL BUT- WE STILL ARE
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL- REGARDING
THE MANDATE ON THAT. IRONICALLY
DESPITE THE- PREVIOUS TESTIMONY
ARGUES THAT THIS IS
INCONSISTENT WITH ST WALL STATE
REGULATIONS AND STATE POLICY IT
IS NOT CLEAR TO US WHY. THERE
SHOULD BE SEPARATE STANDARDS
FOR EMISSIONS BASED ON A
VEHICLE ON WHO IS OPERATING OR
DRIVING THE VEHICLE- INTO OUT
THAT IS ARBITRARY AND THERE'S
BEEN NO REAL WORLD RATIONALE
DISTRIBUTED TO Y. THE FIFTY
YEARS OF REGULATORY PROCESS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AIR
RESOURCES BOARD HAS REGULATED
THE AUTO INDUSTRY ON A
MISSIONS. SHOULD NOT CONTINUE
AND WHY AGAIN IT SHOULD ONLY BE
DONE BY A GUY WHO'S DRIVEN
DRIVING THE VEHICLE WE ALSO
BELIEVE THAT IT HAS THE
POTENTIAL OF LIMITING OPTIONS
OF A YES THEY ARE PART OF HIS
VEHICLE MANUFACTURERS DEVELOP
THE VEHICLES- AND IT IS DRIVEN
BY A GASOLINE POWERED ENGINE
THAT IS LEGALLY DRIVEN IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA UNDER AIR
RESOURCES BOARD OPTIONS BUT
SUDDENLY WOULD NOT BE ABLE. TO
DRIVE THIS VEHICLE AND SALAS
WITHIN US NINE SHORT YEARS WE
DON'T UNDERSTAND THAT- IT'S
AGAIN WE BELIEVE THE TWO MAJOR
PROBLEMS WITH THIS. IT'S HAVE A
SEPARATE STANDARD. FOR V. AND
IT ALSO LIMITS THE VALUE AND
THE PROMISE OF OUR ECONOMY THAT
CAN HAPPEN FOR THOSE WHO HAVE
MOBILITY OPTIONS INCLUDING THE
ELDERLY AND THE DISABLED AND WE
RESPECTFULLY WOULD REQUEST A NO
VOTE ON THIS BILL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU MR OF THE
STEAM- WE'LL MOVE THE PUBLIC
COMMENTS I'LL REMIND YOU THAT
STATE YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION
AND POSITION ONLY AND WILL BE
BEGIN WITH THOSE WITNESSES- IN
THE CHAMBER IF THERE ARE ANY.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS-
PATIENTS TO FOR THE NAME OF MY
ORGANIZATION PLEASE I'M WITH
CALIFORNIANS WHO SUPPORT HONEST
DEFINITIONS OF ZERO EMISSIONS
AND KNOW THAT ELECTRIC
UTILITIES TO BURN COAL AND OIL.
TO CHARGE ELECTRIC CAR
BATTERIES DO NOT RESULT IN ZERO
EMISSIONS WE OPPOSE THE BILL.
THANK YOU. SEE NO ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN THE CHAIN. I
APOLOGIZE THANK YOU. THE
AFTERNOON CHAIR SANTIAGO AND
MEMBERS MARK GRAHAM ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIANS AGAINST
AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES BECAUSE
THEY RELY ON HAZARDOUS NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION ONLY
NAME ORGANIZATION POSITION ONLY
WE ARE MOVING TO THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION. AND WE'RE
TURNING OFF THE MICROPHONE. ANY
WITNESSES IN THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION. I'M NOT
SEEING ANY. MORE HEARING ANY
NOW WE'RE GONNA MOVE FOR TO-
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
WITNESSES- ON THE PHONE AGAIN
STATE YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION
AND POSITION ONLY. TRICIA SUB
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION FOR SB
FIVE HUNDRED PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. IN
ORDER FOR OUR FIRST PLAN NUMBER
TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY EIGHT IS
GO AHEAD. HELLO AND AB SORGEN
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF. WIRELESS
RADIATION. EDUCATION AND DEFEND
AND WE ARE AGAINST AUTONOMOUS
VEHICLES WHICH HURT BECAUSE
THEY ARE DANGEROUS. EXTROVERT A
LINE ONE HUNDRED AND THIRTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
KATIE STEPHENS SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF NARROW IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB. FIVE BUT I TWO
HUNDRED AND FORTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MISTER CHAIRMAN WE
GUARANTEE MARC BERMAN NINETEEN
GENERAL MOTORS AND FORD. THANK
TWO HUNDRED AND FORTY TO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON- MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE KATHY LYNCH
REPRESENTING PLUGIN AMERICANS
STRONG SUPPORT SB FIVE HUNDRED
THANK YOU. TWO HUNDRED AND
FORTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THAT NUMBER. EVEN UNDERGONE
FORTY THREE PLACE BUT- THIS IS
BILL MONTHLY ON BEHALF OF
ELDERS CONNECTIONS NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
CHAPTERS AS WELL AS THREE FIFTY
SILICON VALLEY IN STRONG
SUPPORT. FIND ONE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
STEVEN JIMENEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN LUNG ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT SB FIVE HUNDRED THANK
YOU. THANK ONE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE HUNDRED AND THIRTY THREE
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ABOUT A LINE ONE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD-
OPPOSED. THANK YOU. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE ONLY PROVIDE ANOTHER
LINE NUMBER. THANK TWO HUNDRED
AND FORTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI THIS IS KATHY CARRIAGE WITH
THREE FIFTEEN BAY AREA ACTION
IN STRONG SUPPORT. WE HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU. I WILL
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. WE WERE
FIRST. THIS RUN SECONDS. AND
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED
APPROPRIATIONS- INSTRUMENT
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
TEMPERATURES AGAIN THIS WEEKEND
AND WE ARE IN THE MIDST OF A
CLIMATE EMERGENCY THIS IS A
VERY PRACTICAL BILL I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU SENATOR- MEN
AND MICHIGAN IS DUE PASSED
APPROPRIATIONS MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ITEM
NUMBER SIX SB FIVE HUNDRED
MOTION IS DUE PASSED
APPROPRIATIONS SANTIAGO HI.
SANTIAGO AYE PATTERSON.
BOERNER HORVATH BOERNER HORVATH
I BRIAN. BRIAN AYE BENNETT
DAVIES. DAVIS NOW. EDUARDO
GARCIA. HOLDEN LOW QUICKSILVER.
QUICK SILVA AYE RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ ISLANDERS. BUILDERS
NOW WEBER. WEBER HI. HIS AT SIX
KNOWS TO THE BILL'S ON CALL.
THANK YOU NOW WILL PRECEDE THE-
CUT ITEM ONE SB SIXTY SIX
MISTER ALAN. REVERSE THE SECOND
STATED MR BRYANT. RIGHT FIGURES
TO TURN MEMBERS THIS IS A BILL
THAT AND WE JUST HEARD ABOUT
AND THE SENTIMENTS BILL ABOUT A
THOMAS VEHICLES THE QUESTION IS
ARE WE REALLY PREPARED FOR THE
INFLUX OF AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES
ON EVERY LEVEL- ARE WE PREPARED
ON THE PLANNING SIDE WE
PREPARED ON THE ENVIRONMENTAL
SIDE. WE'VE WE'VE DONE SOME
STUDIES IT SHOWS THAT I THOMAS
VEHICLES COULD BOTH BE AN
INCREDIBLE BENEFIT FOR SOCIETY
IN TERMS OF HOW WE GET AROUND
IT THEY COULD ALSO BECOME MAKE
THINGS A LOT WORSE- THERE WAS
AN EXPERIMENT THAT WAS
CONDUCTED BY UC DAVIS AND UC
BERKELEY THAT MIMIC LIFE WITH
THE NAVY BY PROVIDING EACH.
PARTICIPANT HOUSEHOLD WITH THE
SHOW FOR AND OF COURSE TURNS
OUT THAT WHEN YOU HAVE SOMEONE
ELSE DOING THE DRIVING HAVE
FOLKS USE THE CAR MORE IN FACT
THE EXPERIMENT SHOWED THAT
HOUSEHOLDS TRAVEL 83% MORE
MILES PER WEEK WITH MORE THAN A
FIFTH OF VEHICLE TRIPS CARRYING
NO PASSENGERS AT ALL SAYING HEY
YOU KNOW YOU CAN'T FIND PARKING
THIS GO AROUND THE BLOCK A FEW
TIMES WHILE I'M IN THIS
MEETING. NO HARM NO FOUL SO THE
QUESTION IS HOW DO WE. CREATE A
SYSTEM TO BETTER PLAN. I AM
THIS BILL CREATES A COUNCIL TO
DELIBERATELY PLANNED FOR
AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES IN A WAY
THAT SUPPORTS THE STATE'S
SAFETY TRANSPORTATION CLIMATE.
EQUITY AND SUSTAINABILITY GOALS.
AND THAT'S WHAT THE BILL THAT'S
IT'S- IT'S ALL ABOUT
ALTERNATELY MAKING SURE THAT WE
ARE SMART ABOUT THIS THAT WE
SEE THIS COMING. AND WE PLANNED
FOR IT. I WE WORK WITH MANY
STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING INDUSTRY
GROUPS AND AUTOMAKERS
ENVIRONMENTALISTS. AND OTHERS
WHO WE KNOW WILL BE IMPACTED BY
EV'S TO DRAFT A BILL THAT PUTS
CALIFORNIA ON A PATH TO. TO
PROPERLY PLAN SO HERE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT I HAVE ELIZABETH
ERVIN. FROM THE UNIT CONCERNED
SCIENTISTS ALSO JACQUELINE BACK
WITH WITH THE ASSOCIATION FOR
UNMANNED VEHICLE SYSTEMS
INTERNATIONAL. THANK YOU MISTER
SENATOR BECAUSE WE HAVE TWO OF
THE FOUR MINUTES. NO NOT NOT
DONE BOTH AT TWO. THANK YOU. MR
ONE IF YOU'D LIKE TO BEGIN.
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
COMMITTEE THIS IS A LIVE EVENT
SENIOR TRANSPORTATION ANALYST
AT THE UNION OF CONCERNED
SCIENTISTS. I AM I AM PLEASED
TO BE HERE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
THIS TIME AS ACT B. SIXTY SIX
WHICH ESTABLISHES AN ADVISORY
COMMITTEE ON ECONOMIST VEHICLE
TECHNOLOGY. I MADE VEHICLE
TECHNOLOGY HAS THE POTENTIAL TO
SIGNIFICANTLY ALTER
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM WITH FAR
REACHING IMPLICATIONS FOR
CARBON EMISSIONS AIR POLLUTION
SAFETY EQUITABLE MOBILITY IN
THE STATE'S ECONOMY- AS THE
SENATOR MENTIONED- SOME OF THE
STUDIES ADDITION POINTING IN
THAT DIRECTION. THIS BILL WILL
SET UP A PROCESS AND FORUM GET
DEVOTED TO DIRECTING THE
DEVELOPMENT AND DEPLOYMENT OF
AUTOMATED TECHNOLOGY TO
MAXIMIZE POTENTIAL BENEFITS AND
MINIMIZE POTENTIAL HARM
CRUCIALLY THIS BILL PROVIDES
FOR REPRESENTATION OF A DIVERSE
RANGE OF STAKEHOLDERS AND
EXPERTISE. AND ALSO REQUIRES
THE COUNCIL TO CONSIDER PUBLIC
AND- INPUT AND COMMENT. THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK WITH YOU TODAY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU TO VOTE.
IN FAVOR SB SIXTY SIX THANK YOU.
OBERSEE WITH THIS- BECKWORTH.
BECKWITH I APOLOGIZE ABOUT THE
PRONUNCIATION. MISTER MODERATOR
IS A- RESPECT WITH THEIR PLEASE.
I DO NOT SEE THEM ON THE PHONE
AT THIS TIME WELL. I'LL GIVE
THE SENATOR SECOND TO CHECK IF
HE'S STILL IN NEED OF THAT
SECOND SUPPORT WEAPONS LET'S
JUST GO AHEAD OKAY THANK YOU WE
HAVE NO FORMAL OPPOSITION
LISTED OF THIS BILL- AND IN
LIEU OF THAT I WILL ALLOW- I
WILL ALLOW YOU TO DO- THE TWO
MINUTES AND- WILL END AT THAT.
TWO MINUTES CORRECT. CORRECT
THAT WILL NOT LISTED SO ALL ALL
AT LEAST LIST ONE. THE TWO
MINUTES WILL BE VERY EFFICIENT-
GENERALLY AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES
COME IN MANY DIFFERENT FLAVORS
BUT ONE OF THE THINGS YOU
SHOULD REALLY UNDERSTAND IS
THAT MULTIPLE PARTIES NEED TO
BE ABLE TO INPUT AND WE
APPRECIATE THAT IT HAS A BROAD
RANGE OF PEOPLE ON THIS
COMMITTEE. BUT SERVING FOR
FOURTEEN YEARS WITH THE
FOURTEEN YEARS IS TOO MUCH FOR
SPECIAL INTERESTS TO INFILTRATE
SOME KIND OF ADVISORY COMMITTEE
PLEASE TURN OVER AFTER EVERY
FIVE YEARS TO GET MORE POINTS
OF VIEW ACROSS THAT'S VERY
IMPORTANT. GONZALEZ MY VEHICLES
COME IN MANY DIFFERENT FLAVORS
SOME ARE ACTUALLY SELF
INCREASED ALL THE TECHNOLOGIES
ON BOARD YOU DON'T NEED TO TALK
TO ANY WIRELESS INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT'S WHAT'S BEING TESTED
RIGHT NOW ALL OVER THE COUNTRY.
THERE'S SOME KIND OF FALSE IDEA
THAT SOMEHOW YOU HAVE TO
CONNECT INTO A WIRELESS CELL
TOWER IN ORDER TO HAVE
DRIVERLESS CARS THAT'S NOT
TRUE. AND SO WHAT HAPPENS IS A
LOT OF THINGS IS LOADED ON TO
THE PROMISES OF FIVE G. THERE
WILL NEVER BE DELIVERED. AND
THAT WHOLE THING THE EXTENT TO
DIGITAL DIVIDE AND TELEMEDICINE
AND ALL PROPAGANDA YOU HERE AND
ALL YOU HAVE TO DO IS GO BACK
TWENTY YEARS OR THIRTY YEARS HE
SAID THE SAME THINGS ABOUT THE
SUPER INFORMATION HIGHWAY
NINETEEN NINETY THREE. WHAT IS
ONE THING I HATE TO INTERRUPT
YOU AND I'LL CONTINUE WITH IT I
LIKE TO REMIND YOU THERE SIR OF
OUR SOCIAL DISTINCT POLICIES
FOR THE BENEFIT OF THE SERGEANT
PLEASE THANK YOU. AND I STATED
THAT OVER AND OVER THANK YOU I
APOLOGIZE ABOUT THE
INTERRUPTION YOU MAY PROCEED
THE ABOUT AN HOUR LEFT WE
APPRECIATE I'M ALMOST DONE HERE
ALL I REALLY WANT TO DO IS
ENCOURAGE EVERYONE TO PAY
ATTENTION TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
TREASURY THE PUT A STAKE IN THE
GROUND THAT SAID. EVERYONE
NEEDS FOR BROADBAND FOR THE
DIVIDE. SYMMETRIC ONE HUNDRED
MEGABITS DOWN ONE HUNDRED
MEGABITS UP THAT'S THE ONLY WAY
YOU'RE GONNA GET MONEY ON THE
DEPARTMENT TREASURY WE SHOULD
HAVE THE SAME STANDARD HERE
CALIFORNIA WHICH MEANS IT CAN
ONLY BE DONE BY FIBER OPTIC
CABLE. WIRELESS. WON'T CUT IT.
THANK THANK YOU VERY AND THAT.
THE OUR FORMAL. SUPPORT
OPPOSITION. WE WILL NOW MOVE
THE PUBLIC COMMENTS. IT WILL BE
WHEN I GET THAT RIGHT NOW
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT OPPOSITION
WITNESSES IN THE CHAMBER AT
THIS TIME WE'RE ONLY DOING STE
YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION AND
POSITION ONLY- MAY PROCEED
THANK YOU- GOOD AFTERNOON. MR
CHAIRMAN I APPRECIATE YOUR
PATIENCE ON THE ORGANIZATION.
MARC GRAHAM ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIANS OPPOSED TO
AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES BECAUSE
THEY RELY ON HAZARDOUS HAZARD
DOES MICROWAVE RADIATION WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THE BILL THANK YOU.
SEEING NO OTHER- WITNESSES IN
THE CHAMBER WILL READ WILL-
LOOK TOWARDS THE REMOTE-
TESTIMONY STATION. DON'T HEAR
SEE ANY SO- MISTER MODERATOR. I
THINK IT HELPS OUT WITH A PLUG
IN ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION WITNESSES ON THE
PHONE AGAINST YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION ONLY.
TO SHOW SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE THAN THEIR
OWNER TELEPHONE. AT THIS TIME.
WE HAVE CURRENTLY SUPPORT OF
THIS COMING TO THIS TYPE. THANK
KNOW WE GO TO MEMBERS. IS THERE
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. NOT
SEE ANY SO- MR CENTER WE GOT
CLOSE YEAH THIS BILL RECEIVED A
THIRTY NINETY ZERO VOTE IN THE
SENATE I'M JUST ANSWER SOME OF
THE CONCERNS THAT WERE RAISED
ON THE COMMITTEE MEMBER SIR FOR
FOUR YEAR TERMS NOT FOR
FOURTEEN- WE REALLY DID REACH
TRY TO CREATE A BROAD RANGE OF
STAKEHOLDERS TO PARTICIPATE.
AND I WILL SAY THAT THE BILL
THAT THE BILL IS NOT- PRO
TENNIS VEHICLES ARE AGAINST
CONSTABLES IT JUST SAYS IF THIS
IS HAPPENING WE OUGHT TO BE
PLANNING FOR IT AND IT'S WITH
THAT SPIRIT THAT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK WHEN I BOTH. THANK YOU HAVE
A FIRST AND SECOND. YES YES WE
DO HAVE A REFRESH. MISS
RODRIGUEZ SECONDS THANK YOU-
THE MOTION IS TO PASS
APPROPRIATIONS MY SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ITEM
NUMBER ONE SB SIXTY SIX MOTIONS
THE PAST OF PREPARATION
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I PATTERSON.
BOERNER HORVATH BOERNER HORVATH
I BRIAN BRIAN I'VE BEEN IT
DAVIES DAVIS I EDUARDO GARCIA.
HOLDEN HELLO HELLO I
QUICKSILVER QUICKSILVER I
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ I CALAVERAS
ODORS I WEBER. WEBER I THANK
YOU MEMBERS. THANKS NOT AYE
AYES NINE NOES ZERO DOUBLES ON
CALL. THANK YOU MA'AM SECRETARY
TO WE RETURN TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE- ABSENT MEMBERS CAN ADD ON
TO THE BILL'S. AT THE START OF
THE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS IN
THE MEANTIME. CONSENT FILE ITEM
NUMBER FIVE SB THREE NINE FOR
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. ANDERSON
BOERNER HORVATH.
BOERNER HORVATH I BENNETT
EDUARDO GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA I
HOLDEN. LOW. HELLO I RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ I. IS TEN NO ZERO
THAT BILLS ON CALL. I AM NUMBER
ONE SB SIXTY SIX MOTIONS DAY
PASSED APPROPRIATIONS PATTERSON.
SENATE EDUARDO GARCIA EDUARDO
GARCIA I HOLDEN. IS TEN NO ZERO
THAT BILLS ON CALL ITEM NUMBER
TWO SB FIVE FIVE SIX THE MOTION
IS DUE PASSED APPROPRIATIONS
PATTERSON. BENNETT EDUARDO
GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA I LOW.
LOW I. AYE AYES NINE NOES ONE
THAT BILLS ON CALL ITEM NUMBER
THREE SB FOUR THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
PATTERSON. BOERNER HORVATH.
BENNETT. LOW LOW AYE QUICK
SILVA. QUICK SILVA I. RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ I. IS EIGHT KNOWS TO.
THAT BILLS ON CALL. I AM NUMBER
FOUR SB THREE SEVEN EIGHT THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED
APPROPRIATIONS PATTERSON.
BENNETT HELLO. LOW I WAS ELEVEN
NO ZERO FIVE BILLS ON CALL. THE
ITEM NUMBER SIX. SB FIVE
HUNDRED. THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED APPROPRIATIONS PATTERSON.
BENNETT EDUARDO GARCIA EDUARDO
GARCIA I HOLDEN. HOLDEN I LOW.
LOW HI. AYE AYES NINE NOES TO
THAT BILLS ON CALL. WE'RE STILL
WAITING. FOR HOUSE. NO WAY OUT
PATTERSON. ITEM NUMBER TWO SB
FIVE FIVE SIX MOTIONS DO PASTOR.
PATTERSON. PATTERSON I. BENNETT.
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ I. I WAS
ELEVEN NO ZERO THAT BILLS ON
CALL.
I'M. THE CONSENT ITEM
FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE SB THREE
NINE FOR THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED APPROPRIATIONS PATTERSON.
THE CONSENT. SB THREE NINE
FOUR. PATTERSON I BENNETT.
HOLDEN HOLDEN I. TWELVE IS
TWELVE NO ZERO THAT BILLS ON
CALL. I AM NUMBER ONE S. B.
SIXTY SIX THE MOTION IS THE
PAST APPROPRIATIONS PATTERSON.
PATTERSON NOT VOTING. BENNETT
HOLDEN HOLDEN I. IS. ELEVEN NO
ZERO THAT BILLS ON CALL. I AM
NUMBER TWO SB FIVE FIVE SIX THE
MOTIONS DO PASSED
APPROPRIATIONS. BENNETT. IS
ELEVEN OH ZERO THAT I MEAN I.
KNOWS ONE THAT BILLS ON CALL.
ITEM NUMBER THREE SB FOR THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED
APPROPRIATIONS PATTERSON.
PATTERSON NO. BOERNER HORVATH
BENNETT. IS EIGHT NOES THREE
THAT BILLS ON CALL. ITEM NUMBER
FOR SB THREE SEVEN EIGHT THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED
APPROPRIATIONS PATTERSON.
PATTERSON I BENNETT. IS TWELVE
NO ZERO THAT BILLS ON CALL.
ITEM NUMBER SIX SB FIVE HUNDRED
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED
APPROPRIATIONS PATTERSON.
PATTERSON NOW BENNETT. AYE AYES
NINE NOES THREE. THAT BILLS ON
CALL.
YEAH JUST SAY- WORKING
OUT WITH A CALL FROM THE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE FINAL
VOTE TALLY AND THEN AFTER THAT
YEAH. YEAH YEAH. MADAM
SECRETARY WILL LIFT THE CALL IN
ALL THE BILLS- PLEASE PUT FINAL
TALLIES. THE CONSENT FILE. SB
THREE NINE FOUR. IS TWELVE
KNOWS ZERO. THAT BILL IS OUT
ITEM NUMBER ONE SB SIXTY SIX
ISAIAH LEVIN KNOWS ZERO THAT
BILL IS OUT ITEM NUMBER TWO SB
FIVE FIVE SIX I IS A LEVIN
KNOWS A ONE. THAT BILL IS OUT
ITEM NUMBER THREE SB FOUR. IS
EIGHT KNOWS THREE THAT BILLS
OUT ITEM NUMBER FOUR SB THREE
SEVEN EIGHT. I IS TWELVE NO
ZERO THAT PHYLLIS OUT. I DON'T
NUMBER SIX SB FIVE HUNDRED AYE
AYES NINE NOES THREE THAT BILLS
OUT. I CAN INTERNET. AND WE
DURING THE MEETING.